power bi is a leading business
intelligence tool for performing data
analysis creating data visualizations
and generating reports
according to the gartner 2021 magic
quadrant report for analytics and
business intelligence platforms
microsoft power bi is a leader
hi everyone welcome to this live session
on power bi full course tutorial by
simply learn before we begin make sure
to subscribe to the simply launch
channel and hit the bell icon to never
miss an update
so in this video we will learn what
power bi is and explore the crucial
features
you will understand the different
components of power bi and how to
connect data sources to power bi desktop
you will learn to manipulate the data
and create different charts and graphs
you will understand how to use dax
functions to derive value out of your
data
you will look at the difference between
power bi and tableau
you will learn about data modeling and
create different reports on power bi
desktop finally in this tutorial you
will understand how to create a really
interesting and powerful dashboard and
publish it onto the power bi service so
let's begin business intelligence is a
set of processes and techniques to
analyze raw data and extract information
that helps drive business decisions it
helps you keep track of business data
and draw valuable insights there are
several tools that play a key role in
business intelligence some of the
popular tools are power bi tableau and
clip view in this video you will learn
why power bi is needed what is power bi
the various features of power bi and the
different components of power bi later
you will look at the architecture of
power bi what power bi services and how
to create a power bi dashboard finally
you will understand a case study on myer
and do a demo using power bi now let's
understand why power bi is needed first
power bi has the ability to access vast
volumes of data from multiple sources it
allows you to view analyze and visualize
huge quantities of data that cannot be
opened in excel some of the important
data sources available in power bi are
xl csv xml json pdf etc second power bi
provides an easy to use drag and drop
tool with features and functionalities
that allow you to copy all formatting
across similar visualizations power bi
has exceptional integration with excel
it helps you gather analyze publish and
share excel business data power bi helps
to accelerate big data preparation with
azure using power bi with azure allows
you to analyze and share vast volumes of
data azure data lake can reduce the time
it takes to get insights and increase
collaboration between business analysts
data engineers and data scientists power
bi allows you to get insights from data
and turn insights into actions to take
data driven business decisions finally
power bi allows you to perform real-time
stream analytics it fetches data from
multiple sensors and social media
sources to get access to real-time
analytics so you are always ready to
make business decisions now let's see
what power bi is power bi is a business
analytics service provided by microsoft
that lets you visualize your data and
share insights it converts data from
different sources to build interactive
dashboards and bi reports as you can see
we have an excel data about sales
using this data power bi helps you build
different charts and graphs to visualize
the data now that we have understood
what power bi is let us look at the
important features of power bi first is
power via desktop power bi desktop is a
free software that you can download and
it allows you to build reports by
accessing data easily for using power bi
desktop you do not need advanced report
designing or query skills to build a
report second as already discussed power
bi supports stream analytics from
factory sensors to social media sources
power bi assists in real-time analytics
to make timely decisions third support
for multiple data sources is one of the
major features of power bi you can
access various sources of data such as
excel csv sql server web files etc to
create interactive visualizations
and finally custom visualization custom
visualization is another vital feature
of power bi while dealing with complex
data power bi's default standard might
not be enough in some cases in that case
you can access the custom library of
visualization that meets your needs
let us jump into discussing the various
components of our bi as you can see
there are six major components of power
bi now let's discuss them one by one
first is power query power query is the
data transformation and mass of engine
it enables you to discover connect
combine and refine data sources to meet
your analysis need it can be downloaded
as an add-in for excel or can be used as
part of power bi desktop second we have
powerpivot powerpivot is a data modeling
technology that lets you create data
models it also allows you to establish
relationships and create calculations it
uses data analysis expression language
or dacs to model simple and complex data
third we have power view power view is a
technology that is available in excel
sharepoint sql server and power bi it
lets you create interactive charts
graphs maps and other visuals that
brings your data to life next we have
power map microsoft's power map for
excel and power bi is a 3d data
visualization tool that lets you map
your data and plot more than a million
rows of data visually on bing maps in 3d
format from an excel table or data model
in excel
then we have power bi desktop power bi
desktop is a development tool for power
query power pivot and power view with
power bi desktop you have everything
under the same solution and it is easier
to develop bin data analysis experience
finally we have power q and a the q and
a feature in power bi lets you explore
your data in your own words it is the
fastest way to get an answer from your
data using natural language an example
could be what was the total sales last
year once you have built your data model
and deployed that into power bi website
then you can ask questions and get
answers easily
now let's see what power bi service is
power bi service is the software as a
service part of power bi it is also
referred as power bi online to access
power bi service you need to log in to
app.powerbi.com
now let me show you that i'll go to
google
open a new tab and search for
app.powerbi.com
it's loading
but this is how the homepage of power bi
service looks like i have created some
dashboards on it first you need to log
into app.powerbi service
you can see i'm logged in
now under my workspace if i go to
dashboard
here i've created
a finance dashboard you can see the
different charts and graphs i have
prepared and pinned it to the dashboard
so power bi service allows you to
connect to your data create reports and
dashboards and you can also ask
questions to your data now as you can
see in this dashboard we have created
some charts and graphs so this is a tree
map there's a pie chart there's a bar
graph below you can see the line charts
and donut charts it tells you the total
sales that were made the total number of
units sold the sales by product sales by
country sales by segment and lots more
one of the key features of power bi is
creating dashboards from multiple
reports and data sets power bi dashboard
is a single page visualization to tell a
story the visualizations on a dashboard
are generated from multiple reports and
each report is based on one data set
a single page dashboard is known as a
canvas the visualizations you see on the
dashboard are called tiles
these tiles are pinned to the dashboard
by report designers
now let me go back to my dashboard so
this is called a canvas and each of
these are called tiles so on the top you
can see we have three tiles now let's
understand how to create and publish
reports in power bi dashboards power bi
allows you to create different reports
on power bi desktop these reports can be
published on the power bi dashboard
using power bi service here you can see
there is a power bi report created on
power via desktop if you click on
publish
it will take you to the power bi service
where you can build a dashboard here is
the button for power bi publish once you
click on power bi publish it will take
you to the dashboard so this is a single
page power bi dashboard on power bi
service now let's understand the power
bi architecture power bi architecture is
a service built on top of azure there
are multiple data sources that power bi
can connect to power bi desktop allows
you to create reports and data
visualizations on the data set power bi
gateway is connected to on-premise data
sources to get continuous data for
reporting and analytics power bi
services are basically the cloud
services that are used to publish power
bi reports and data visualizations using
power bi mobile apps you can stay
connected to their data from anywhere
power bi apps are available for windows
ios and android platforms now let's look
at a case study on how mayer which is
one of united states largest supermarket
chains used power bi to solve its
business problems initially meijer had
become dependent on its it organization
to extract insights from its data it was
time consuming and inefficient as you
had to wait for it to build every report
meijer was unable to perform ad hoc and
real-time analysis easily so what maya
did was it connected power bi to an
on-premises sql server analysis services
cube this allowed them to refresh 20
billion rows of data in near real time
with power bi teams can now pull in the
data faster and perform real-time
analysis to derive insights from data a
bakery department inside mayer used
power bi to compare its sales with
regional performance they analyzed where
meyer was behind the regional trends
focused on the problem and created a
solution with power bi they can now
drill down into hourly sales and send
out a sales flash to 800 maya business
leaders so power bi enabled them to
standardize data sources and empower
store directors and team leaders to
develop and track their data to ensure
what they can improve now let's do some
practical hands-on demo with power bi so
this is how the power bi desktop
interface looks like on the left you
have the report view the data view and
the model view the report view is where
you visualize your data with different
charts and graphs to build reports the
data view allows you to view the whole
data while the model view is where you
check if there are any relationship
between the tables
on the right you can see the different
visualizations that you can build we'll
quickly run through all of these in our
demo so here you can see there's a
finance sample data that will help you
draw insights about the sale of products
in different countries we will create a
report to visualize different charts and
graphs and analyze those sales so let me
go to my power bi desktop first we'll
import our data so let me go to our get
data tab and choose excel as my data
source i click on excel so here is our
finance sample data
we'll select sheet1 you can see the data
here click on it and then select load
this might take some time to load the
data now if i go to my data tab you can
see the entire data set it has fields
such as segment country in which the
sales was made the name of the product
the units sold and the sales price and
many more let's start building our
report now i'll go to my report view so
first let me create a text box
let me resize it
let me name it as
finance dashboard will increase the size
of the text we'll use font consoles
center it will also add a background to
this we use blue color change it to
white
and
increase the size
now let me first show you how you can
create a matrix i'll go to
visualizations and click on matrix let
me resize it
from the datasheet tab i'll select sales
and drag onto values
so you can see the total number of sales
that were made now let me do some
formatting so i'll go to the format tab
click on column headers let's add a
background color and let me increase the
text size to
20.
similarly under values will increase the
size of the text
to 20 as well
we can also click on
border and choose the color of the
border let me take as
let it be black so this is a simple
matrix that we created which shows the
total number of sales that were made
similarly let me choose matrix once
again now
we'll drag on the units sold onto values
we'll continue with the same drill under
column headers we'll add a background
this time let's choose some other color
and under values let's increase the size
of the text to 20.
even for the column headers let's
increase the size of the text to 20.
again we'll switch on
border we resize a bit
so here we have two matrix created for
our report
the first matrix shows us the total
sales that were made the second matrix
shows you the total units that were sold
now let's move ahead and create a simple
bar chart so under visualization i click
on clustered column chart
under this we'll drag the date column on
to access and the sales onto value
let me expand it so it shows you the
sales per year this is the sales that
were made in 2013 and this shows you the
sales that were made in 2014.
now there's a drill down option which
gives you more granularity
this depicts the sales per quarter if i
drill down further you can see this
shows you the sales by month also you
have some options like short buy and
sort by sales so you can see october
month made the highest number of sales
moving ahead let me now create a pie
chart where we will see the sales by
different segments
under visualization i'll click on pie
chart let me first resize it
here
i'll drag the segment column on to the
legend and the sales column on to the
values as you can see we have the sales
made by different segments
government segment made the highest
number of sales with 44.22 percent now
let me add a border to both the
visualization i'll click on the pie
chart and go to the format tab
i'll switch on the border similarly for
the clustered column chart i'll go to
the format tab and click on border let
me resize a bit all right next we'll
create a very simple table that will
depict the total sales made by each
product so under visualizations i click
on table let me bring this below
so from the data sheet i'll first drag
product onto values
you can see the different products and
then sales just below it
so this depicts the total sales that
were made by each product and finally it
displays the total value of the sales
that were made this is same as the one
shown here
now let's do some formatting under
format tab i'll go to values and
increase the text size to 15
and expand it
also under column headers
i'll increase the text size to 15.
then let me go and add a border
now let me create a map that will show
you the sales that were made by each
country so first let me create a new
page and under visualization i'll click
on map now i'll drag the country column
onto location
so you can see we have our map ready and
we'll drag sales
onto size
you can see the different countries and
the sales that they made if i move the
map you can see the sales made in the
europe region
let me resize it i'll add a border to
this
now let me go ahead and create a donut
chart that will show you the profit by
each segment under visualizations i'll
click on donut chart
and move this to the top
now from the data sheet i'll add profit
onto the values
and
segment
onto the legend
if i expand this you can see government
segment made the highest amount of
profit with 65.04 percent let me resize
this and we'll add a border
okay in the final visualization i'll
show you how to create a tree map this
tree map will tell you the total amount
of sales made by each product so under
visualizations i'll click on the tree
map let me expand it
i'll drag sales onto values and product
onto group so here you can see our tree
map and the sales made by each product
you can see now we have our report ready
we have created two separate canvas to
visualize our data
now
if you want to change the color of this
bars then simply go to the format tab
and under data colors you can choose
whichever color you want in power bi
desktop you have an option to switch
your theme
this will make your dashboard or the
report look more attractive so now we
are under the default mode let's try out
different themes
that's frontier temperature
solar which is a little yellowish the
one which i like is tidal
i hope this was helpful in making you
understand the basics of power bi and
how it works you learn the various
features and the components of power bi
and looked at the architecture of power
bi finally you saw a demo to create a
report using finance data set in this
video we will learn about the two
important data visualization and
business intelligence tools namely power
bi and tableau this video will help you
learn the major differences between the
two tools
first we will look at the history of
power bi and tableau followed by their
cost
then we will see which of them has
better performance and a good user
interface
after that we will look at the different
data sources to which power bi and
tableau can connect with
next we will get an understanding of the
programming languages that they support
and their data visualization
capabilities
you will then get an idea of how power
bi and tableau support machine learning
and which of them has better customer
support
you will see the current trends of both
the tools and you will understand
where these tools are positioned in the
gartner magic warden for 2020
finally i will tell you how simply learn
can help you start your career in power
bi and tableau
now let's begin with understanding the
history of power bi and tableau
so what really is power bi
power bi is a business analytics service
provided by microsoft it has the
capability to analyze and visualize data
extract insights and share it across
various departments within your
organization
power bi makes data visually appealing
it has easy drag and drop functionality
with features that allow you to copy all
formatting across similar visualizations
power bi fetches data from factory
sensors and social media sources to get
access to real real-time analytics
let's see what tableau really is
tableau is a powerful business
intelligence tool which manages the data
flow and turns data into actionable
information
it can create a wide range of different
visualization to interactively present
the data and showcase insights
tableau has a feature of drag and drop
which allows its users to create
interactive visuals quickly
it can also build interactive dashboards
with just a few clicks
so power bi was originally designed by
ron george in the summer of 2010 and the
initial release was available for public
download on 11th of july 2011.
the key components of power bi are power
bi desktop
power bi service power bi mobile apps
power bi gateway and power bi report
server
tableau software was founded in 2003 in
mountain view california and the tableau
desktop 1.0 was released in 2004. on
first of august 2019 salesforce acquired
tableau
tabloop products include tableau desktop
tableau server tableau online tableau
visible tableau public and tableau
reader
now let's see how expensive these tools
are
power bi is way less expensive than
tableau software power bi professional
version costs less than 10 dollars per
month per user
the yearly subscription comes around
hundred dollars
power bi premium is licensed with
dedicated cloud compute and storage
resources and is priced at
4995 dollars per month
on the other hand
tableau is more expensive but the pro
version of tableau comes at more than 35
dollars per month per user
the yearly subscription costs around
thousand dollars
tableau creator costs around 70 dollars
per month while tableau viewer is priced
at 12 per month if you are a startup or
a small business you can offer power bi
and then upgrade to tableau if the need
arises
now coming to performance
power bi is easy to use it is faster and
performs better when the volume of data
is limited power bi tends to drag slow
when handling bulk data
but tableau can handle large volumes of
data easily it is faster and provides
extensive features for visualizing the
data
tableau doesn't limit the number of data
points in a visualization or enforce row
or size limitations
so you can have a complete view of your
data
tableau's wide range of built-in
analytic capabilities allows you to
spend less time worrying about manually
creating calculations designing
visualizations and formatting dashboards
now let's discuss the user interface of
these tools
the user interface of power bi is highly
intuitive and it can easily be
integrated with other microsoft products
power bi interface is easy to learn and
understand
it is user friendly and allows you to
operate better
power bi desktop provides three views
which you can select on the left side of
the canvas
the first view is of the report view
where you can create reports and visuals
the next is the data view
in this view you can see the tables
measures and other data used in the data
model associated with your report
and transform the data for best use in
the reports model
and third is the model view
in this view you can see and manage the
relationships among data in your data
model
tableau has an intelligent interface
that enables you to create and customize
the dashboards according to your
requirements easily
it has an inviting workspace area that
encourages you to experiment with data
and get smart results
the workspace area has different cards
themselves
toolbar sidebar data source page status
bar and sheet tabs
with that
let us now talk about the different data
sources that power bi and tableau can
connect with
another important feature of power bi is
that it supports various data sources
but has limited access to other
databases and servers
compared to tableau
some of the examples are microsoft excel
text or csv files
folders
microsoft sql server accessdb oracle
database ibm db2 mysql database postgre
sql database etc
tableau software has access to numerous
data sources and servers such as excel
text file pdf json statistical file
amazon redshift cloudera hadoop google
analytics dropbox google seats google
drive and lots more
now let's talk about that ease of use
power bi enjoys a slight edge in terms
of ease of use because it is based on a
user interface that has its roots in
microsoft office 365
which most end users are already
familiar with
tableau provides some essential
advantages for exploring and visualizing
data in detail
tableau is also incorporating natural
language capabilities into its software
this will help us in finding solutions
to complex problems by understanding the
data better
next let us understand how power bi and
tableau differ in terms of programming
support
power bi supports data analysis
expressions or dacs and m language for
data manipulation and data modeling
it can connect with our programming
language using microsoft revolution
analytics but it is available only for
enterprises level users
compared to power bi
tableau integrates much better with our
language
tableau software development kit can be
implemented using any of the four
programming languages such as c c plus
plus java and python by connecting to
these programming languages you can
build even more powerful visualizations
now coming to the most important
category which is data visualization
power bi provides an easy to use drag
and drop functionality it provides
features that make data visually
appealing
power bi offers a wide range of detailed
and attractive visualizations to create
reports and dashboards
using power bi service you can ask
questions about your data and it will
give you meaningful insights
tableau also allows its users to
customize dashboards specifically for a
device
it delivers interactive visuals that
support insights on the fly
it can translate queries to
visualizations and makes you ask
questions spot trends and identify
opportunities
no coding knowledge is required to work
on tableau as tableau provides inbuilt
table calculations to build reports and
dashboards
now talking about machine learning and
how they are different from each other
power bi enjoys the advantages of
microsoft business analytics that
includes platforms such as azure machine
learning sql server based analysis
services data streaming in real time and
many as your database offers
it helps to understand the data and
analyze the trends and patterns in the
data
you can also forecast the data to make
future predictions
tableau supports the features of python
machine learning this enables it to
perform machine learning operations over
the data set
finally let's talk about customer
support
microsoft power bi is relatively younger
in the market than tableau and hence it
has a smaller community
while tableau has over 160 000 active
users participating in over 500 global
user groups and over 150 000 active
customers participating in the tableau
online community
next on the screen you can see the
google trends for both the tools over
the last five years from 2015 onwards
as you can see tableau is a clear front
runner and is more popular these days
with high search volume
now talking about the gartner magic
quadrant for analytics and business
intelligence platforms
so for 13 consecutive years gartner has
recognized microsoft as a magic quadrant
leader in analytics and business
intelligence platforms
and it has recognized tableau as a
leader in business intelligence after
microsoft
you can see there are other popular
tools such as click
hotspot csens
oracle
sas
sap and salesforce
now i will tell you how simply learn can
assist you in learning power bi and
tableau and help you become an expert in
business intelligence
so let me take you to our website
i'll open a new tab
let me search for simplylearn.com
i'll now search for power bi in the
search bar so let me type power bi here
i'll click the first link
which is the power bi certification
training course
so this course
will help you learn about microsoft
power bi desktop layouts
you will learn how to build business
intelligence reports dashboards power bi
data analysis expressions
commands and functions
so this is the course content
you learn about desktop layout features
the views connecting to common data
sources
you learn about the query editor
and its functionality then you will
learn how to create relationships in
your data model
we learn about calculated columns and
measures built-in aggregations
we'll also learn about data
visualizations practices reports and
dashboard layout creating a sales
analysis report and lots more
let me go back
and now
i'll search for tableau
i'll click on the first link
so this is the course for tableau
certification training
so it's around 56 hours of in-depth
blended learning there are four real
time industry projects
you'll get lifetime access to selfies
learning videos
two simulation exams
on the right you can see the skills that
will be covered as part of this course
we learn tableau statistics building
interactive dashboards
this arithmetic logical and lod
calculations which is level of detail
learn about heat map waterfall
pareto clustering forecasting
and here you can see the entire course
content
after learning this course you can go
ahead and take the tableau certification
what is power bi it is a business
intelligence tool to visualize your data
and share insights across your
organization so when we talk about bi it
came into existence as a self-service bi
tool and it does have different
components which can be used now before
we get into details of power bi
let's understand
what are the different components or
what are the different ways in which you
can work on
your power bi now one of the main
challenges when it comes to
[Music]
organizations or users is that data is
scattered in different places
it might be in different formats
and anyone everyone would want to use
that data to basically perform some
calculations
create visualizations or dashboards
which could be interactive
and that's where they would want to
bring all the data in one place might be
transform it so that you can filter out
and not load huge amount of data in your
system and you can work on selective
data so when it comes to power bi it
helps us in etl
it helps us in data modeling it helps in
data storage and reporting now before we
get further
into understanding how power bi looks
like it would be good idea to share
information in how you can set that up
on your machine so when it comes to your
power bi
and let me open up a notepad here
so for example i bring up a notepad
let's say when you talk about your power
bi components
so you basically have
power bi desktop
and that's mainly your playground or
that's mainly used for
any kind of development activities
you have your power bi server
or you can say service so now this one
is where
you would make reports
online
and
share
or
make them available
to different bus
now that's one more component of power
bi and then you also have your power
bi mobile which is mainly for
viewing the information i would say
viewing reports so these are the three
main components we can also look at the
licensing information of these so these
are the main so power bi desktop is
something which you can set up on your
laptop or on your machine
power bi server is where you can log in
with your user id and password and power
bi mobile is mainly to view your reports
now how do you set this up before you
can explore or start working on power bi
so here is a link
which you can basically use
so if you look into this
so this one basically says service self
service sign up for power bi it says
sign up of power bi service as an
individual normally when you would want
to
use power bi you can use a website
called http
and then you have basically
app
and
let's say
i think it's called app powerbi.com
now this is the place where you can
basically log in now if you see here i
have created an account and if you look
at my account
it says auatl.on
microsoft.com now how do you get this
kind of email because when you talk
about power bi it will expect you to
have a official id and it does not take
ids which are from common
domains such as google or yahoo and so
on so this particular link gives you an
idea how you can do that
so basically you have what is power bi
basic explanation on that it says
signing up for power bi service so power
bi desktop it's a totally free download
and then you have mobile apps also a
totally free download and here it says
that what kind of email addresses it
supports
and if you look into this you have to
either
sign up because that does not accept
your private email ids or you can go for
this one which says enroll us government
organization
and this is where you can basically sign
up for power bi so
it basically says try free if you go to
the website say power bi.microsoft.com
or you could go into
this one which i was saying
http
slash
app dot
your power bi.com and this is what you
can use or as mentioned you can go to
powerbi.microsoft.com
for example if i open this in a
different tab
it takes me to power via microsoft i can
say start free
i can click on this
it says try free
but then when it asks you to sign in
this is where
some of us face problem because it does
not take your private email id now how
do you tackle that what you can do here
is
on this page which says learn about
alternate ways to sign up you can
basically open up this link and in this
link it says sign up for power bi with
the new microsoft 365 trial
account and what you can do is you can
basically
click on this link
which takes you to the office 365
and what you can do here
is you can search for something which
says say
e3
and here you have tried for free
so in my case it is translating okay
so here you have an option which says
try it for free click on this one and
then basically go ahead with your signup
process now once you do that you can
basically create an account or give a
email id so it asks you to give an email
id to check if you already have an
account
and once you do that it will guide you
through the process where you can create
an account like i have done
now once you have done that so for
example we can go into
my
this page which i said http
slash app
power bi.com
now once you have created an account you
would be asked to login now i can click
and log in here
and then basically given my password
and once i do that it takes me to the
power bi server or service now
on the top
right it might say that go for a trial
version i have already selected that and
this is a pro trial which is giving me
validity for 60 days so this is the
service which i can use now what it
means is i can be using my power bi
desktop which would be also installed so
once you
log into this page you can basically
click on apps you can basically search
for something like power bi
and that will show up in the app and you
can install and download on your machine
now once that is there you can basically
bring it up so for example in my case i
can just say power
bi desktop
and that's the app which i have
installed on my machine
and basically that comes up so that's
your power bi desktop which is coming up
and
it will still ask you to sign in so that
you can share your information
through power bi so you see here on the
top i'm already signed in
and here it also shows you some
tutorials and videos
which basically helps you in getting to
know something more or what's new so you
can always browse that
so you would have your power bi desktop
which would be set up
you would also have your power bi
service which would be running and then
basically whatever you have developed on
your power bi desktop you can share that
through the power bi service now usually
when you talk about licensing i can give
you brief insights here so you basically
have
your
power bi service as i said licensing so
you have the pro version
which is basically
uh your
9.9 dollars
per user
per month
and basically it has some kind of
limitation so it has say max 10 gigabyte
you can work on
some features like incremental refresh
is not allowed you can always look onto
the microsoft website for more details
and in those kind of cases you usually
go for the premium account if you are a
extensive user and premium account
basically is conditional base so it
depends on your requirements and then
basically you pay for the service what
you use so that's mainly about your
servicing now when you talk about your
server and service as i said it is
basically making your reports online and
sharing and making them available to
different bus so that is
the highlight so when you talk about
sharing reports
that's one of the things you have
anomaly detection
that's also possible here
you can talk about automation of reports
you have
security that is you can go for role
based or row level based kind of
security implementation and all those
are some of the features of your power
bi server and service so it is good to
know and basically have your desktop and
power bi service setup now once you have
that then you basically have your power
bi now
when you talk about your power bi it
basically helps you with various things
so this is how easily you can have it
set up and then basically you can
explore this so for example as i was
saying power bi can connect to different
data sources now i do have an option
here which says get data
i can click on this and that shows me
all the different data sources i can
even click on more if i'm interested in
looking what more power bi desktop tool
helps me to do so it shows me all the
different ways in which you can get the
data you see here the servers so the
database services your folders your
different formats you can click on file
formats or databases
you can look at power platform so if
basically you are connecting to a
platform and getting some services you
can connect to the cloud that is azure
you have online services and then you
have other options so these are all the
ways in which you can get your data when
you talk about visualizations you see a
lot of
visualization options here which can be
used once your data is loaded
and i will explore and explain more
about this so you have
something called as insert
wherein you can go in for different
visuals or different types
you can also get into say transform the
data now that basically is going to pop
up and bring a power query editor now
that's where a lot of your etl works
happen so when you when you do a
transform data it opens up power query
editor
which we can use to transform the data
or change the data or modify the data as
per our requirement before loading all
of it into our power bi
so you also have option here which says
modeling wherein we can create new
tables or we can work on our data where
we can manage relationships so as of now
we don't have any data so it does not
show this one is activated but that can
be activated this is where you can view
your reports so this is in short
exploring your power bi we'll see what
are the different options which we can
use here
so
it basically supports different kind of
data so when we look at the
visualization pane that
basically allows us to create different
kind of visualizations here and we will
understand that
so
you can basically visualize on your
different data
and create different kind of charts
graphs maps and basically derive
insights from your data now when you
talk about data models that's where you
can
basically establish relationships so
when you talk about data models it is
basically used to connect multiple data
sources to build a relationship now we
might have different data sets or we
might have data coming in from different
tables where we may want to basically
get insights or get data from multiple
data sources
for our purpose now in that case data
models to help us so for example if you
have two tables let's look at the
standard tables so you have products
lookup table
and you also have the sales table now
usually what you have in any kind of
scenario is
if we basically say you have
your data tables so that's basically
where your data resides and then you
have series of your lookup tables so
usually you might have say your data
tables here
and this is what i'm talking about which
might have some data for example let's
say
sales is one of them
you might have some other data table
which might be for example let's say
budget table
or might be something else
and
these are your data tables now at the
other end you might have your lookup
tables so basically you have various
lookup tables
and these lookup tables for example
let's say this one is customer
this one is territory
let's say this is product
and let's say this one is a calendar
so these are basically my lookup tables
so we can
basically as i said your data might be
coming in from different sources let's
say database or let's say some kind of
files or let's say
some kind of systems what you have
so your data might be coming in from
different places now
you might want to transform the data so
this is where i could say there is your
query editor which i was explaining
so you have your query editor which
basically allows you to edit the data
table or basically allows you to edit
the data before it is loaded right you
can hide a column you can add a new
column you can modify your column so
your query editors would be basically
used to work on
the data which goes into your data
tables now
you might have a lot of lookup tables as
i said so let's say these are my
lookup tables
and these are my data tables
so what we need is sometimes we need
information
based on our lookup tables and data
tables now that's where data modeling
comes into picture so basically if i
would want to extract information from
here so i can notice that there is a
product key here
and there is a product key here now this
is where we are already talking about
say foreign keys or we are talking about
your relationships right now when you
talk about relational databases you have
something called as foreign key
constraints which is
in in power bi terms i would say it's
not exactly a constraint but it is more
of a filter propagation instead
which is used to basically connect your
different data sources and you could
have
basically
cross filter directions you can go for
single
or one to one or one to many or many to
many kind of relationships which
basically allows you to work on the data
so we will learn more about data models
when we are doing a quick demo there
where we can talk a little bit about
normalization and denormalization
the way the data exists
right and then you basically would want
to gather insights from your data so
when you talk about your
two data sources as i said so you have a
products lookup table you have a sales
table now if you would want to calculate
the total order quantity of each product
name which is we are talking about the
order quantity as a
information here and you have product
name here now how do you get that
information what we see here is we would
want
something like this or we would want
more information so how do we do that so
what we can do is
the order quantity for each product is
basically showing us the same value now
this is because the product and sales
tables are not connected and there is no
relationship between them even if you
would want to take two sources and just
get information out of them probably i
would complain that there is no
relationship established between them so
what
we do is we create a data model so what
we do is we build a relationship between
both the tables using a common key
column which exists in both cases as i
said there is a product key here there
is a product key here so that basically
allows us to have a relationship between
these two now that could be
one to one this could also be related to
other tables so it could be one too many
you could have many to one so all those
relationships are possible so product
key is basically used to create a
relationship you see the arrow mark and
then there is also the star which can
basically mean one to many now
when the product key is used to join
these two tables or form a relationship
then we can look at the product names
and the order quantities which basically
gives me a total now that's the basic
use of your data models now what about
this dax so basically data analysis
expressions now that's a
library of functions and operators that
can be combined to build formulas and
expressions and power be a desktop
usually when we work on our data sources
when we would want to connect them it
automatically shows us these data
analysis expressions however this gives
us
extension it basically gives us more
power to work on our data
now sometimes instead of working on dax
or dax expressions it would be good to
go for better data modeling and have the
relationships established better and
sometimes when the relationships are
established you could use your tax which
basically gives you more power on
working on your data so your values are
calculated based on information from
each row of a table
it appends values to each row in a table
and stores them in the model
it increases the file size so that's
what happens now you can right click on
any column to add a new column and for
example in this one it shows that there
was a quantity type calculated column
which was based on the calculation what
we see here on the top in the in the
expression bar which says what kind of
calculation was performed and that
basically gives us the value for
quantity type and that is basically
added here to our existing data
so that's the
power
of dax and power bi so you also have
something called as
measures so dax allows you to create new
calculated columns and measures
so basically here if you see we are
working on aw underscore sales and then
we have selected quantity sold
and
what we are looking in the report is we
can basically right click on any table
name to add a new measure here so we
have added what we call as quantity sold
as the measure so values are calculated
based on information from any filters in
the report we will see this how this can
be done and that basically here the
measure does not increase the file size
it does not create new data in the table
themselves in comparison to what we were
seeing earlier that is your calculated
columns
so these are your type of dax functions
so dax allows you to create new
calculated columns and measures
so you have date and time which
basically allows you to work on date and
time
data or fields you have logical
functions which allow us to create new
filters or add more filters to our data
you have text functions which basically
allows
us to say transform the data into a
lower case or an upper case or basically
get the length of a string or
concatenate two fields
or basically
do a filtering based on some criterias
or replacing some content you also have
statistical functions which can be used
you have information functions which can
be used so these are different types of
dax functions
which we can use in power bi
so we will learn more on power bi
through a quick demo where we can
use some data sets and those data sets
could be found on internet although i
can also upload that on a github link
and you will have access to those data
sets
so let's learn about power bi through a
quick demo
by uploading some data sets and playing
with those data sets
let's
look at this sample data set and let's
upload it
and as i explained while uploading let's
also transform the data so that we can
have selective
fields so selected data loaded here
instead of loading the complete data set
and then let's see how we can visualize
this or how we can use the information
in this data set now what we can do here
is we can click on get data and then we
can choose one of the data formats which
we would be
looking for so for example i can go for
excel
and basically
click on this now here are some of my
data sets
so let's look into
the folder here
and
these data sets are also available on my
github link which i'll share with you
later so here we have something called a
super store let's click on this and here
i already have a data set which is
global super store or i also have
selective data so let's
select this one
click on open
now
that's basically connecting to my data
source and that will show me what does
that excel sheet have so it has
different tabs
which is orders people and returns so
let's select orders
and that basically gives me a preview of
the data which i have and if you scroll
all the way to right it shows me city
state
and then country and if you see here we
do see information of all the countries
now this can be huge amount of data
which may which we would want look into
but say for example my use case is that
i'm interested in looking for the data
for united states and
as a country and all it states so we
will do that when we do a transform
now we can also select the returns tab
and that shows me
these three fields however the first row
should have been the heading
of this
particular data set and we will
transform that now i can go ahead and
click on load but that will load all the
data so instead of that let's go for
transforming so let's click on transform
data now once you do that it brings you
your toolkit that brings you your power
query editor which allows you to
transform your data so for example we
have
our data from returns tab or returns
data source as you see here so we see
column one column two and column three
and that also shows the type of
the data here
it also gives me a quick small option
here let's select this and then i can
say use first row as header now there
are various other options which you can
do you can add a custom column you can
add column with examples you can keep
the top rows
you can remove the top rows you can keep
errors keep duplicates so there are
different ways and you can also do a
merge query or append query so as of now
let's just say use first row as headers
and that basically shows that now my
first row has become the header you also
see
in the applied steps it basically tells
me
if i have changed the type of the data
if i have made any other changes those
steps will get added here so it
basically shows me the name as it
returns it shows me applied steps where
i have changed the type
and now i basically have this
information now this is something where
you can change the type or you can
basically
set it to a particular format however we
are not doing anything of that sort
right now
so we can do that for any of these
columns so this looks good
when it comes to orders let's click on
this and as i said i would be interested
in selecting for country as united
states only and let me just work on that
data however we can work on all the data
so let me scroll all the way to right
and here i have the country now there
are these filters which we can use
so basically i can click on this and
that shows me all the countries are
selected now there is also something
called as text filters which we will see
how we can use to select particular data
i basically have
other ways of filtering the data so for
example now i will just uncheck the
select all and what i would be
interested is in united states so let's
type it here that shows me has an option
here
select this
and then basically say okay
so that should basically now filter out
and it shows me the data is united
states
only and then you have different states
and rest of the data remains so if you
look at the applied steps it tells me
that there are filtered rows
now we have done the basic
transformation for this data set
on these two data sources that is orders
and returns so here you have an option
which says close and apply so close the
query editor window and apply any
pending changes you can click on this
and it says apply
so for example i can just say apply for
now and that should basically apply the
changes
which i have performed
using my query editor that is i have
transformed the data so that i can have
selective
data uploaded in my power bi now it's
doing that it shows me it is working on
both of these data sources that is
orders and returns so that's done and
now basically if there are any other
pending changes we can
just do a close and apply
so that basically has closed and now you
would see the data appearing here
so i have uploaded the data
as per
my preferences now if you click on
the data tab here
so it basically shows you your data
fields it might take some time to
populate but if you see in the country
field now
if even if i click on the filter it just
shows me united states now that's what
we wanted so we have already uploaded
this data in orders you can always
expand the
option here which shows me all the
fields which are there in this might be
this is an aggregation might be that's
an ordered date so this is again some
kind of aggregation we can change the
data types so we are looking at all the
fields in my orders table or basically
coming from the orders data source i
also have returns which shows me three
fields and that shows me the data which
is returned order id and region so the
column names are applied correctly as we
want and that basically looks fine now
we can also look at
your
model so when you click on model it
shows me these two however there is no
as of now relationship established
between them so it says
under properties select one or more
model objects to set their properties so
right now these are not related there is
no relationship established between them
so if i would want some data which
relates to orders and returns
then that would fail because it would
say there is no relationship now i can
go to
the first option which says report and
we have not created any report here
although we can create a simple report
we can look at the data so we have our
orders field now
we can basically pull out some
information from here we can choose what
kind of report we may want to create so
for example let's go for
the table option from visualizations you
have various options here which we can
use
this is where you can do a formatting
this is where you can select the fields
this is where you can search and filter
out the data you can also add data
fields here so first let's click on
table
and that basically gives me a table now
this table
as of now does not have anything so you
can use the filter and slices
option here which will affect the
visualization or basically what you can
do is now since we have
orders here so this is my orders and i
would like to work on this so let's say
for example country is
i can select country as a field and if
you say
it shows me country is all as of now and
it says the value is united states what
i can also do is i'm interested in the
states
so i have state now i can basically drag
and drop it here and then the state gets
added here so i can basically say select
all
and that should basically take care of
my
state field being added here
so state is all country is all
now
we can basically look at something else
so might be let's choose sales
and i can just drag and drop sales here
so that basically says if you would want
to have any kind of advanced filtering
which says filter type so go for
advanced filtering is less than or equal
or you can also go for advanced filters
so that's fine as of now so we have
added some fields here
and that's basically
my data here
so
let's go for
filters here
which basically should select all my
fields
now if you see the visualization shows
my country
sales and state which we had either by
selecting the fields and dropping
them here or you can in this section
where it says field so you can for
example let me show it again so i can
just delete this
i can click on the table option
i can just drag it here
i can basically make it bigger and i
need to add data to this one so it says
add data fields here so now let's say
country
is what we are interested in we are also
interested in states
so let's drop that here and let's say
sales so this is also what i'm
interested so i'm looking at one
specific country i'm looking at sales
per state and when we look at
sales it basically tells me that this is
summation so you will basically get
the total sales which have happened now
we are looking at this data here we can
always go to formatting we can click on
grid we can basically increase the font
here we can change the grid color
so for example let's make it for example
blue
so i can just select this
and it should basically
allow me to have the grid color as blue
now i can go in for the grid thickness i
can go for row padding outline color so
we can basically make it a little bit
more readable
and then we can basically increase the
font size here
to look at the information
and you have other options here so what
would you want to do with column headers
so i can basically have the font color
background color is fine
do you want to have an outline
do you want to have a change in font
what is the text size might be we can
make the heading a little bigger
and then basically you also have the
field formatting so all those could be
done you could go for background and all
these things can be done in formatting
so now we already have our data here and
this
basically looks good and this is
basically
one of my visuals
which i have here and this has given me
some information for sales and basically
i can scroll this i can
also make it bigger
so i could select a particular field if
i'm more interested in looking at the
information for a particular state now i
can add more fields to this
so this is
my
one of the reports which i have created
now
what i can do with this report is i can
basically have more data fields i can
add filters to this
i can basically look into all the data
here by just clicking somewhere in the
grid but somewhere outside if you select
a particular row then that data shows up
here you have an option of focus mode
which you can go for you can look at the
other options which says export data now
if this is the data which you are
interested in
you can export it you can always to
show as a table if you are interested in
you can do a sort by country sales or
state so for example let's do a sorting
by state
and that basically gives me the data
which has been sorted by state
information
now we could obviously have
the information here so i can then
change the order so it shows me
alphabetically this is the information
which i have so i've created a simple
visualization using the data which i
have and what i can do is i can click on
save so that basically asks me to save
this as a power bi file which has an
extension of pbi x and i can basically
call it my report so let's say
first
report
and here i can say country
or i can say
state
wise
sales
in
usa
let's say
and that basically is my first report
now
once you have saved this report you can
always look on your machine for example
if i go in here
and if i go into this folder might be i
should look on desktop
and
this is where i should have saved it
so it shows me first report statewide
that will open up in power bi and we
have created a simple report which we
have basically used by taking our data
now i can also do is i can publish this
if i would want to share this
information so
publish this report online in power bi
service
you can basically select
your report what we have here and i
clicked on publish so it says what's the
destination so you can have different
workspaces i will choose the default
that's my workspace i can click on
select now it says publishing first
report statewide sales in usa to power
bi you can create a portrait view of
your report and you can do all that
stuff so let it publish and then we can
basically look into our power bi server
that's a service where the information
is already shared
or published i would say which can then
be shared with different resources so we
can come here
and basically i can look into the power
bi and this is where i will be able to
look into my workspaces and let's look
in my workspace so it says this is the
place where i had initially downloaded
power bi data set it says your data set
is ready let power bi help you explore
your data right so you can always do
this you can click on view data set
which basically allows you to
bring out your workspace and first
report state y sales now that's the
report which we have published so let's
first check in our desktop if that's
done so it says
success open first report in power bi
now i can click on this one straight
away and that takes me to my service
now once it takes me to the service it
shows me
the report which we created
which we published and it basically has
the option where i can save it
as
a
a different copy or give a different
name i can embed this in
a website or a portal i can publish to
web
embed this report for public access by
anyone on the internet we can do that we
can export it to powerpoint so we can do
all these options you also have an
option of view where you can change the
view you can basically also edit report
here so you can do that if you are
interested in something specific
you can do a sharing to teams so if you
have your teams or groups set up you can
share it with them
you have an option of common pains you
can basically
view usage metrics report now that can
be sometimes helpful
you can basically go ahead and go
and subscribe a particular report so if
there are new changes made you will be
the one who will be informed you can
click on share now if i click on share
here from my service it says only users
with power bi pro will have access to
the support recipients will have the
same access as you unless row level
security on the data set further
restricts them so i can grant access and
this is where i will have to give the
email ids of the people
with a message
that i would want to have them
look at this report
right you can also allow recipients to
build new content using the underlying
data sets and you can send an email
notification to the user so as of now i
don't have any other groups so i'll not
be sharing it but i have created a
simple report now let's also look at
edit report let's just to see what it
helps us and when you click on edit
report it basically brings up this one
which says your file view
it gives you the filters it basically
allows you to add data fields to this so
it is basically giving access to these
data sets which were in my desktop
it is basically allowing you to give or
create different visualizations
now here we have the data which we are
looking at and if say for example
somebody is interested in filtering the
data so you could do that so you could
click on filter here and that basically
applies this is the filter we have now
country is fine sales
might be i can click on sales and i
would say okay let's look at
sales which is more than a particular
amount so we can say is
greater than
and might be i can give a number here so
i can say 30 000
and basically
i can say apply filter
so right now i'm liking filter and i
would look at the values
which also shows me the total value is
changed so
you have not only created a report you
have published it and now
from the service you can edit it so i'm
looking at particular data here and then
basically i can click on file and i can
save it or i can say save a copy of the
report and let's say
i will call it
the same name so i'll say first
report
underscore
state wise
sales
and i will say modified
so let's do a save
and the report has been saved
so now you're looking at the data here
so
that is basically giving you information
so when i click on my
workspace here
i can click on reports and that does
show me my previous report it shows me
the modified report it gives me an
option of looking at the usage metrics
report so say for example you want to
click on this one and it will basically
give you the usage metrics so let's
click on this one
and
that basically shows me the report usage
metrics which is generated so views per
day unique viewers per day
you would want to look at the different
platforms who was using it views by user
and this can be sometimes useful if we
would want to look into this one now i
can go back to my workspace i can click
on reports
and that basically
took me to usage metrics i could be
sharing it
i can analyze in excel
i can look for quick insights based on
this data what we have
you can basically look at the related
information you can also look at the
settings of this one
and basically this is how you have your
data report here now that also shows me
the data sets option so which basically
gives me
the data sets which can be used to
create further reports
and we have our data here
so
for example if i click on create report
it basically gives me these data sets
and we can continue working on this so
this is how i have
a simple report created without
basically working on two different data
sources but i have selected some data
here
and then i can basically add details to
this so for example now if we look at
orders and say for example this is the
data i have
and say you would want to add some
fields so let's go to returns and say
for example i would be interested in
looking at
the the products so might be what i
should do is i should replace the report
here instead of country it would be
interesting to look at
the product
which we have or basically customer id
so we can look at customer id we can
look at the order id which would be
interesting to see if there is a
particular order
what was the sales which was generated
and if there were any returns which were
happening on that so for example here
when i have these let me cut out country
as a field and i will basically take
order id and place it here
so now if you see my data has been
easily modified
so i have my order id i have sales and i
have
state wise information so
you have basically all the information
but this is now order id state and so on
now what if i would want to
also see
based on the order id if i say i would
want the returned field
so for example i would want to take this
one and let's drag and drop it here
now that says cannot display the visual
now why is that so if you click on see
details that says cannot determine
relationships between the fields so it
cannot display the data because power bi
cannot determine the relationship
between two or more fields
and how do we fix that so for example if
i click on fix this now it says
there is a missing relationship between
these fields use auto detect to search
for relationships or create them
manually now i can click on auto detect
which will try to search for fields
which exist in both the data sets or
basically i can create relationships so
let's click on create relationships and
that basically takes me to this page
which says there are no relationships
defined
from table to table and so on
so
i can click on new
now here it says select the tables and
the columns that are related now i can
say orders now those are my fields where
you have order ids and it automatically
shows that returns also has an order id
field although all the values might not
be same but this is how you can create a
relationship and it says the cardinality
says many to one so you can have
basically many to one relationship you
are saying cross filter direction is
single
so make this relationship active and it
has already helped us basically
identifying the field so i can say okay
so it says
now these two tables should be related
or should be connected based on order id
so
here we have this and let's basically
say close
now
once that is done
if you see
i have order id i have returned
i have sales column and i have state and
if you see in returned i do have a value
of yes
which shows
this particular order id
had generated some sales
and it was for state alabama and it was
returned
and the value is yes so if you scroll
down you basically see all the values
now we can add different filters where
we can say i would want only yes and no
now this is again an interesting report
so let's go in also into the formatting
and what we can do is we can look at
say the grid option if we would want to
basically say vertical grid and let's
say
on
and it says vertical grid color so let's
select this might be i can try doing a
black here it puts it in the right nice
table format and that basically looks
good so you have
sales
returned and so on and this is basically
the order which i am seeing here so for
example if i would want to
change the order and if i am saying okay
i would like to look at sales and
returned and so on so we can be doing
that we can come here and say for
example i have sales and return let's
try
moving the sales column over here
might be state is
an information which we would want in
the beginning so let me also
move the states all the way here so it
gives me state it gives me the order id
sales and if
there was
a return which was happening on that
particular product so easily i've
modified my report now what i can do is
i can just save it
and i can do the same thing so i can
publish it i can basically continue
using it or i can work on a new report
so let's continue learning and
now here we will also see
how you can load some data and perform
some transformations and basically get
multiple results or multiple tables or
multiple data sets which can be then
further used for reporting so power bi
does give you a lot of options now here
you have an option as we saw earlier
that is get data
or what you can do is
you have an option where you can create
new data also it says enter data now
this is something which can be easily
used if you have
relatively
less number of fields so you can
basically add
more
columns here and you can basically add
values so for example if i would just
call it something like
scientist id
okay and then i can say scientist name
and then basically i can say
domain
and then i can say for example let's say
year of joining and
and i can keep adding the number of
columns here i can delete the columns
right and i can give this and i can say
country
so
that's it and now we have created these
five
countries sorry five columns which we
have given some names and we can start
entering some values so
i can basically say let this scientist
id be
22 3 4
i can give some name so let's give peter
let's say domain and i can say
biotechnology
i can give year of joining 2011 and i
can say germany as the country
and i really don't want this particular
column so i can go ahead and delete this
now i can come here
and then i can give something else so i
can say this is scientist id
i can give john
let's say
the scientist is mainly working in
physics
and then i can say 2018 and let's say
france
and go back here and let's say
four five six seven and let's say
marie
and let's say
she does her research in
uh molecules and let's call it 2001
and let's say
italy
okay and you can continue adding data in
this way now you can
say if the data is already here so i can
say for example no i do not want
this particular row
i do not want
so
you can basically keep adding values
here now you can say edit
so
here we have to give some name so let's
say
scientists
okay
and then
if you choose edit
it basically brings up your power bi
editor which allows you to work on these
fields if you would want to make some
changes now we can make some changes
here we can see
what are the number of rows we can
basically perform any kind of
transactions here so this one basically
tells me what is the data type so here
we see scientist id and this clearly
tells me this is an integer however we
will not want to do any kind of
computations here so
we can as well change this so i can just
do a right click and i can work on this
particular column what i can also do is
i can just click on this
and this tells me that you would want to
change it to
date time or you want to change it to
some number so i can just say string
because we are not going to perform any
computation here
so on the id column so let's say text
and i'm changing it so it says replace
current add a new step so selected
column has an existing type conversion
would you like to replace the existing
conversion or preserve the existing so i
will say replace current and now the
data type has been changed it is
of a string and if you see this step has
got added here so it says that
the change type
is the kind of transformation we did
here so that's fine now what we can also
do is we have the scientist name but we
don't like the column name here so it
would be good to change this
so there is something called as
remove or remove columns and so on so
when you do a right click it gives you a
lot of options in applying filters or
doing some transformation if i just
click on this one so what i can do is i
can look at the date time and
let's go here so we have
an option which says do you want to
change the type now we could have done
that here or like i said you could
choose the time and do it you can just
say transform and how do you want to
change it so do you want to change it to
uppercase well you can do that and
changes all the values of this one
what i can do is i can again do a right
click and
i can choose
basically if you would want to clean up
the data or if you would want to convert
to lowercase you want to capitalize each
word
so let's choose that and if you see here
the steps are getting added now to undo
any particular step if i just
cancel this then i'm back to this if i
cancel this i'm back to my original form
so you can anytime undo your changes
and you can basically work on this so
we are working on this particular column
now there are various other options that
you can look at so for example these are
this is some of my data but it does not
have much information it would be good
to load some bigger data set and then
use these transformations or basically
working on changing the data types as i
mentioned
or if you would want to do a filtering
and remove certain fields and only
select particular fields if that's what
you're interested
doing a right click where i want to
create a copy of this and then basically
i can
use that particular copy
now what i can also do is
i can add column from examples i can
duplicate column and then i can
make some changes to that so this is my
duplicate column and say for example
you would want
this one to be changed so
we can
say remove duplicates we can basically
if you are doing some kind of change you
want to change the format here you can
do that you can use for other things
like filling up and all that now i can
just call it rename and let's say
um
alias scientist name
right and i can continue adding columns
or i can do some transformations and
once you have done with these
transactions now this one if you see it
shows as integer but is it an integer no
this is an date format so i can go for
modeling and change the formats what i
can also do is i can select this and it
says it's not a decimal it's not a fixed
decimal it is date time it is date
it is date time and time zone
right and you can select any one of
these so for example let's make it date
which
makes it more meaningful but then what
happens is when you do this it is going
for the default dates or the older dates
so i don't like that
so what we will have to do is we will
have to
basically transform this and
here we have transform you have change
type
so you have date and time you have date
you have time so let's choose date and
time and if you see here it gives me
some default timing based on these
values which we do not like so again
filter it out but what we can do is we
can just
make sure that this is
changed or you want to make it a string
because we are not going to do any
computation here so i can keep it as
date but then if i have more fields like
month and days and so on then you can do
that so here it also has
the option so when you have selected
this you have an option called transform
and transpose sorry transform also has
various options which allow you to work
on these do you want to do some
scientific calculations do you want to
work on
the date field so as of now it is just
integer so we can use one of these we
can do a group by but
obviously we don't have much data here
so as of now let us retain this i can
just change this to text and that's okay
because we are going to look at this
later we can add more data and work on
it so as of now once we have done all
these changes you can go back to
say home and here you have close and
apply and i can basically say close and
apply so the changes will be
applied and then my new table which we
just created by entering some random
data
performing some basic transformations
will be available so if you look into
this one
so that's where my data is it shows me
the columns but there is no aggregated
column as such here you don't see any
summation mark you just see the field
names or the column names you see the
values now obviously if you go into
modeling
there is no
or there is no existence of a different
table which you can join these tables or
you can perform some transactions
come back to the data set so this looks
good and we have it here now obviously
we have not created any visualization
based on this which we can and we can
continue working on it so here this is
my data set
which is a small table where we have
created some data and we can use it
anytime
now let's work on a bigger data set and
see what kind of transformations we can
do we can then also see on modeling or
basically using some smarter ways of
working with the data
so what we would want to do is we would
want to
load some data here
so let's go into
sorry let's go into home let's go to get
data
let's use our old store data and i'm
going to take the global super store
which is huge data set with
all the countries and the products and
the sales which have happened
and we can take this data but before
loading it as i suggested earlier we
should basically transform the data we
should basically transform the data so
that you don't end up loading everything
and you don't work on all the data i
mean unless you really want to
so here i will this excel sheet which
i'm talking about has two different tabs
we have used it before so let's use
orders let's use returns
and that basically shows me the data
what we have so i can do a load but
that's not what we would want to do so
you can do a load and you can get all
the data but let's go to transform
make some basic transformations before
we load the data so our power
bi editor allows us to work on this now
here we have
it says this preview may be up to nine
days old
so i can do a refresh i can select this
and i say first thing is use first row
as header because that's what i want
so it is basically
setting the first row as header which
looks good
and we have some order ids we have the
returned if the product was returned so
let's look at the filter here so it just
has
yes values
which we are looking at
so
it says list may be incomplete let's say
load more
and let's see what are the filters here
so either there might be a product which
is returned or it might be blank field
so that is chosen so that's fine we have
order id we have region which is
basically showing me different regions
here
let's look at orders and orders
is again having your row id order id
order date
ship date ship mode so you have quite
large amount of data here for your
different countries now in earlier
example i chose united states and then i
was only focusing on the states and city
in united states so we can do that now
i can basically work on refresh so
whatever preview was stored in the
memory we are just refreshing it now
here we have this
row id and if you see the row id is an
integer obviously we will not be
performing any kind of computation here
so
here you don't have any row id but here
we have row id so let's make it
uh from integer let's make it string
and
i'll say replace current so that's that
looks fine it's a row id which we will
use to search but we are not going to
perform any computations unless you want
to find on
an average on row id or anything else
now you have order ids so
what we can do is we can
filter some values
we can rename the field as we desired
right so for example let's go in here
and what we can do is let's go into
a customer id ship
okay
and here you have say state you have
region
okay now at any point of time if i would
want to filter out the values the easier
option is
that you can select on this one and here
you can do some text filtering
okay or you can basically select the
values from here so for example
if i say let's get rid of
select all
what we will be interested in
say united states and uk that's the data
we want and then
i can basically say okay
so
it is basically going to filter out the
data which is for united states and uk
as of now now what we can also do is how
about doing some more filtering before
we basically work on this so let's go in
here and we are looking at united states
and uk related data
and let's look at
it is sometimes good that you can
basically
work on the data here so for example i
go into orders now what i would want to
do is i would want to look at
the fields
okay
and we want to we have not yet loaded
the data so if you look in the
background i just have my scientists
because we have not applied these
changes we have not loaded we are still
in the
transformation stage right now what we
can do is let's go for
so we can do
segment and all these kind of fields
can be used for grouping the data so we
will see that whenever you have a data
set you would already know there are
certain fields which have repeated
values which can be used to group the
data
and we can do that we can
change
any kind of values which are not
going to be computed on so for example i
have postal code i can
use this but again we are not going to
find a postal code which is greater than
something right so integer is not the
valid type let's change it to text
okay
and
if for example
i would want to
look at this so i have done some
changes here
okay and this shows me null so for
example let me just reword this back
and let's make it
a whole number
okay so there are
certain columns or rows which do not
have some values and we can basically
get rid of those values so as of now we
can do a filtering here
so let's keep the postal code as integer
or
let's change it to text do a replace
content
and now what we will do is we'll scroll
all the way right
might be i'm interested in
technology category so that's what i'm
interested in so what i can do is here i
can do some filtering
so i can basically choose
technology now the easier way would be
since these are categories and there are
only three categories we really don't
want to go and apply text filters here
but if you had something like an office
supply
and
office inventory
then you could have done some text
filter so let's not do some text
filtering here what we can do is i would
be interested in technology
so that's the field i'm interested in so
now you are only having data which is
related to technology
okay and you have some product names so
this is where we want to do some kind of
filtering
so
we can rename the field we can select
some fields so let's for
example let's go for
[Music]
any of the field which i think might
have more entries here so for example
let's go for
canon wireless or canon image right so
let's go for product names
and i will say let's
go here
now i could have done a transformation
but that's not what we want we want to
do some filtering so let's go to text
filter
and here
i can say begins with
i can say ends with i can say contains
so let's go for contains
and it says enter a value here so
you would want to keep the rows where
the product name contains something and
it gives you some suggestion
right so where you are seeing in some
values here so for example if i would
have selected this then it applies the
complete thing but that's not what i
want so i will
get rid of all this and i will say it
contains canon now i can go for advanced
filtering also
okay
wherein you can select advanced and then
you can give
different columns
and
what do they contain
what kind of values you're looking for
so you can do that but we will not go
for advanced in one step let's go for
basic and let's say okay
and now
i should get all the products which are
canon
and you have different products so this
is one kind of filtering i've done it
tells me what is the category of this it
is machines it is copiers
it is obviously belonging to the
technology category we are looking at
the market which is for this particular
data when you look at the country we are
still focusing on united states and
united kingdom that kind of data right
so we have filtered the data we have
done some
selection based on the data here and
what i can do is i can then
basically
rename a particular field
so i can do that i can say i'm
interested in
sales
which is the data here
we can
basically look into the quantity so
sales is something which we are
interested in but might be we are
interested in sales which are
more than a particular value i'm not
interested in lower amount of sales i
would want to look into united states in
uk data but i am interested in sales or
i am looking at
if the discount percentage was something
or if the profit was
more right so we can apply different
kind of values here but
what we can do is with these changes
because you don't want to transform and
make changes all here
you want to make the changes once the
data set is uploaded so we have selected
some data we have create done some
transformations we can basically
break a particular column into multiple
columns if that's what we want if we see
that we will do an aggregation based on
here
or we will do a aggregation based on the
country or year and order id right so we
can break this data into multiple
columns so we can do that but for now
let's do a close and apply
and
let's apply this so that's going to
apply all these changes it's going to
load my data but remember now we are
having selective or selected data which
gets loaded
so that should get be available here so
it takes time sometimes
so you have to wait
and then you can go ahead and check here
so for example now i'm looking in tables
let's basically minimize this let's go
for orders and this is the data i have
which obviously row id if you see
so you have all the row ids and again
again you can do filtering here but this
is where you have already loaded the
data the data is available
and then you can start working on the
columns here
so we have this
if you closely see we see this summation
mark and this basically means that
these are my aggregated columns or these
values are measures which can be used
for calculations so we can see that we
can create our own aggregations so we
can do that we can rename the field as
we have seen
we can filter out the data so we have
all the fields showing up from orders
and let's also look at the returns
which basically has the columns the
order id and your region
so
it basically shows the region here where
was the
product returned from and we have this
information so what we are doing is we
when we were doing a text filter in the
previous example
remember it was case sensitive
okay and you have to take care of when
you're doing a text filter you have to
give a field which exactly matches as it
exists in the content now
okay this is the data we have and let's
look at the order column right now what
we can do is we can do some quick
transformations here
and we can basically look for
more data here so
let's say we have
some filtering to be done now
i can do a filtering based on my
products
so we had all these products but now
let's do a filtering on product and then
products you have copiers you have
machines
so you have
mainly two categories right and when you
look at machines it basically talks
about your pc
something so let's look for machines and
here
we have
basically the copier fields which are
more
so i can basically
go for filtering here
and that's the data we have so we don't
want to really unselect any of these
here
but what i'm doing is i'm saying text
filter and let's go into this one now
and let's say contains
okay so i'm saying contains and then i
can basically say
let's say copier
now that's what i'm interested in
and
show rows where product name contains
copier
okay now you can give a and condition
here
so
if you would want a specific copier if
you are interested in okay let's also
say
uh contains and let's go for laser also
laser
and let's say okay
so you see the data gets filtered out
here and
we have the sales which we are seeing
here so let's go to sales and we will be
interested in anything above
500 so let's go to sales
let's go for number filters let's say
greater than
and i will say for example 500 or sorry
okay
and
let's say okay
so that basically filters out the data
and then
i am also interested in quantity where i
would want
the quantity to be
more than
1 or more than 2 so for example so let's
go in
here
and you can basically choose what is the
filter you want so you can apply any
number of filters now you have the
filtering here you can always click on
the filter and if you want you can just
do a clear filter and the filtering will
be gone so you have all the data right
and
this is
the particular data we have and here i
have say for example
product name now i can keep the filter
because i am interested only in these
values or
i can filter out so this tells me that
when we did it and
it is basically going for laser and
copier right so
let's say for example clear all filters
the thing is gone what we can do is
let's go here
go for text filters say contains and
here i will say
it can be a copier
okay or
so last time we did a and and i'll do it
contains laser
so
let's choose this that gives me more
entries so either the product name has
copier or it has laser
it has the quantity it has the product
name
and we have all this detail here now
what we can also do is we can do some
transformation
on the product id so for example you
have product id or order id so order id
shows up as
looks like the country name
uh the year and then the order id so we
can basically
split it up so i can select this and
here
i have option of
let's go to home so when you have you
have selected this column so you have an
option of transform data here so use the
power query editor to connect prepare
and transform the data so if you really
want to transform the data here if i
basically select this
if i
just where i click here now here it just
tells me do you want a new column do you
want to create a copy of this column
okay you want to create copy table so
this is your transformed data what you
have and for example let's create a copy
table
and let's come in here
so
you should be able to see your
copy table now so let's go in
and select this one
and what you need to do here is creating
a copy of this or copy table
would not be the right option what we
can do is we can work on
transforming this rather than doing it
from here so you have this option of
adding a new column going for a new
measure
renaming it right so that's
okay but what we can do is select this
particular column let's do a home
and first thing is let's go to transform
so i want to transform the data
now let's select this one
and it brings up your power editor again
here we were interested in orders so we
are looking at
our data here
now if you see my countries united
states and uk so you can confirm that if
you look at category it is technology
product name has copier and laser as we
selected so those things are retained so
you have not lost any changes as of now
so this order id column what we have now
as i said you can be doing a filtering
okay you can select this particular
column and then you have other things
which can be used to transform here like
you want to change the data type you
want to use first row as header you want
to replace some values
okay you want to run some merge queries
you want to do some analytics so all
these options are here now what we can
do is while this column is selected i
can do where i click now there is an
option called transform which is
basically going to help me in changing
the data here okay now i can basically
duplicate the column so i really don't
want to work on this column itself but
it would be good to have
a duplicate column on which we can work
on so i can do a split column here if i
would want to but let's create a
duplicate column so let's say duplicate
column
now that gives me a duplicate column so
we can rename it later so now i will not
work on my original column but i'll work
on a duplicate column and what i'm going
to do is i'm going to
basically transform or split this so
again where i click
now you have a split by so we can say
split by by delimiter or by number or by
characters or by position so by
lowercase and uppercase so you can do
all of this so let's go for by delimiter
now if you see
it basically identifies the delimiter
which is hyphen or dash
now you can go for split at left most
identify right sorry left most delimiter
right most each occurrence of delimiter
and that's what we want to do you can
look into advanced options where it says
split into columns
so do you want to split that into
columns do you want to split that into
rows because that's more or less like
doing a group by and you can say number
of columns to split into
so we have here one two three four
values so that looks good to me
and
let's do
say for example if i choose 3
so i can choose 3 and then split using
special characters so you could do that
so let's for example let's say okay
and let's look at the data how it looks
like we can anytime delete the data we
can keep it the way we want right so
what we did was
we created a copy of the column
then we did a split
and
what we have seen is we just have three
columns now if you see the fourth bit is
gone fourth bit doesn't show up right
because i just did a three
as the
resulting column so i have the order id
okay and we can check if there is
already an order id column so we have
order id but that has the complete
order id here and the
relatively product id so you can see the
customer id you can look at this one so
it basically has
your order id and then let's look at
the fields here
so we have
the product id which says t e c m a i'm
looking at the first one 3 7 0 0
and
that has in no relation to the order id
right so we can make sure that there is
nothing which is
conflicting with our entries now once
that is done so we have order id which
can be used to categorize the data
you have order id which is basically the
year
okay and you have order id
which is
basically having some more value now i
can keep this data as i want so i can
basically click on this i can go for
renaming and i can say let's say let's
call it
order
id
and let's say
ids so let us
in case there is
a particular column and you would want
to look at
so
just give the name correctly now order
ids is fine
so here we will also rename this one so
let's call it
uh
order
year
and that's going to be ordered here so
we can again change this to
string
okay and here you have the order id so
let's rename this one
and i have my
let's call
order
number
right
so we have we are seeing all the steps
which we have added here we just split
the data based on the delimiter and we
have
now three new columns which have got
added to our existing data which was
already filtered
and we have done some splitting up of
data by creating a duplicate and then
renaming it right so if you
go and look at your transformations now
if i would have done a split here
straight away then my original column
would be gone but probably we want the
original column because sometimes you
may want to search order id with a
consolidated information sometimes you
may want to segregate it based on year
right now we have the year field or
order date field here you have the ship
date right but then might be you want to
just aggregate based on year you don't
want to really spend time in aggregating
or extracting the month and day and so
on so my these three columns can be
useful now what i can also do is i can
merge the columns if i want so we have
split the columns but what i can do is i
can say select
select
so using your control and now do a right
click so you should have an option
called merge columns right now this is
something which is
we would want to merge
so let's say merge columns and let's say
do you want to keep a separator so yes i
want to keep a separator but might be
this time i will give my separator is a
colon
and then what is the merge column name
you want to create so let's call it
something like
um
order
okay
uh
year
and then let's call it
num
right so sometimes renaming the fields
to a name which makes more sense or
based on your naming convention is good
so let's do a merge
and
now what i have done is i have done
merging of those columns
so
i split the data i merge the columns and
now if you see my
the columns which i had created those
columns are gone because you did a merge
you did a merge and now you have the
fields which are either
earlier you had
something which is
separated by
a
hyphen and here you have
something which is separated by colon
right now anytime if you want you can
unmerge this by removing this step right
and you can get rid of this merge column
so if for example i would do that
so
i have my data back
right i have my data back so what we
could have done is we can select this
okay and then what we can do is like
what we did earlier
so you can
basically
go for
removing the columns
okay you can do a merge column
okay
you can select one by one and create
duplicate of those and then you can
merge them right so all the possible
options are there so you can the best
option would be to create a duplicate of
these columns and then basically merge
them as per your convenience so might be
you can say order id is an order number
is the pairing what you want here is
something which you don't want right
because we already have the date field
so i can basically say remove
and this one is gone now i will select
this and this
and let's go for merge columns and
i want to give a separator which
is might be without the ear and you have
space
or you can go for custom like earlier we
had
give a
symbol
and then what do you want to call it so
let's say order
specs
okay
right so this makes more meaning because
we already have the date field so why do
i want the year into my order id so i
can always be doing a segregation now
based on order specs
right now this is some simple
transformations what we are doing here
we are seeing the
data which we have
okay now what i can do is i can
basically first apply these changes
so that all my changes what i have done
are applied
right now once these changes are done we
can basically go ahead and
save this file
so i can just say save i can go for save
as i have different other options so
if you would want to
perform keep performing your
transformation then you can just do this
you can add a column you can view the
data so for now our transformations are
good enough and what we can do is we can
basically
go back to home we can do a close and
apply and we will be back to
our data set which has been modified so
we can see
if the data what we have has been
transformed
so we have ordered specs here that's
good
we did not do any filtering or
we we have the filter left here which
basically tells me that there are these
different fields we have not removed
them but what we are doing is we are
just applying a filter to choose copiers
and laser printers
so that's what we have here and this is
good enough now what i can do is once
this is done
i can basically save it
so i would want to call it some kind of
report if you would want to create okay
so let's call it
as
[Music]
let's say second
report
and here i will say
country
and
technology
specific
info
let's save it
and now basically i have saved my data
so what you can do is you can go for
creating other report or basically
having this information published if
that's what you want to do if you want
to go for visualization because right
now what we are seeing is we have lot of
data here we have a lot of data here
it shows me there are these
tables or data sets which we have worked
on that shows me
here in the models but there is no
relationship with them
if you go into visualization then you
don't have
any option or you have not created any
visualizations based on this data but if
you go here
now based on the data what we
transformed if you see
we
have order specs
right now that's what we chose
we basically have other fields so you
have ship date you have aggregated
columns which can be used for
visualizing and we can work on this
so i can come back here and what i would
be interested in
is this data set is fine but i want to
do some
grouping i want to
basically
have some selective data in this
and for that what i can do is
let's go for ship mode now this is
something what we have so
we are in this
data field
now we have this transform so let's go
back to transform again
and let's choose our orders
so that's the data we have
and now if you see here this is
you know huge amount of data what we
want is we want to group them based on
the shipping mode
so here you have an option called group
by so i can select this
i can go in here
i can basically work on okay get rid of
duplicate values but that's not what we
want to do you want to do a group by so
as i said you can do a group by from
here or you can choose from the
transform option above and you can do a
group by so let's do a group by
now
how do you want to group the data so i'm
saying i want to group the data here
based on shipping mode
or
which is the other column you want to
use to do a group by so let's go for
shipping mode
and what is the new column name
right so we want to basically find out
that
you want to go for ship mode but
that's not enough i mean i can do a ship
mode and i can do a grouping by but you
want to just count the rows no that's
not what we want to do so let's go to
advanced so ship mode is fine so that's
your grouping right but then what we
also want to do is we want to do a
grouping based on
say sales
so here for example let's go for sales
okay
and what should we call this so might be
we can say
shipment
wise
sales whatever you would want to call
so you can basically
get
the operation do you want to really
count the rows no we want to basically
do a summing or we want to
might be find out an average price right
so let's do a sum
okay and
here
i would want to do a summing based on
say for example
sales
so this is what i'm going to use for
getting a count of the sales now
grouping by might be we will change this
instead of
[Music]
instead of sales we are using a ship
mode what we can also do is let's go for
a segment
and that would be valid grouping so it
will take a combination of ship mode
segmenting group the data based on that
and then get me the sales which is
which is basically let's call it
shipment wise sales
so it gets a sum so let's do a
okay
and that's my more relevant data which
i'm looking at so i'm looking at the
ship mode i'm looking at what is the
segment
and then i'm looking at what is the
total sales there i'm looking at
again the ship mode standard and home
office so always remember when you are
choosing multiple fields or multiple
columns for grouping by
you are basically having
a combination of two fields so that has
to be unique and your grouping is done
based on that so now you're looking at
the sales wise
and this is something as
an important information what we have
so we have done some transformation
and what you can do is
you can use
other ways like you can use pivot to get
individual values from it you can run on
merge queries which is
basically running some merge queries and
merge the query with another query in
this workbook if you have so you can go
for this now i can basically go for
apply and close
so just to add to the group by step what
we did was if you see here i have
removed the group by filter which we
just did a couple of minutes back and
what i have done is instead of
transforming your complete data set
you can basically create a copy of it so
for example i can just do a copy
and then i can come here and do a paste
and i have done that and i'm calling it
order summarized but this is my complete
data now what we will do here is we will
basically go ahead and do a grouping by
again like what we did earlier based on
your shipment
based on your segment
and
based on the sales so that's what we are
looking for so let's go for the ship
mode
and
we go for group by
and here you would want to go for
advanced to ship mode
and this one i will go for segment
so that's fine now we want the new
column name so let's say
shipment
wise
sales
so i want to do a summing not the
counting of rows and i want to do a
summation based on sales like what we
did earlier
and then you say okay
and that basically
gives you the data here now
what we have is we have the resultant
data based on the data which is coming
in from here we did the same thing just
one minute back
but we worked on the original data set
so what i did was i created a copy and
now i'm working on this one so i'll say
close and apply
and now we are back to
our
desktop
so it is applying these changes where we
have done some transformations we have
done some grouping by and what we can do
is
once we have the data here we can
anytime look at our data sets or tables
so this is my original one
if you see now i have order summarized i
can just pull out this information
i basically have my
returns which we have not really touched
and we have the scientist so we have all
the four data sets here
now what we can also do is
let's look into order summarized and we
just have this data here so
this is fine and you can continue
working on this you can basically
merge columns from two different data
sets
and then you can get
the merged column
and you can rename it so you can
obviously do that
you can basically do a uncheck
whenever you are working on these data
sets so what you can do is
if you would want to work on
transforming for example let's go back
here
and say i want to do
some transformation on it so how did we
do it we just did a transform
and
you can go back to transform
so you have this data here and
the data what you have you might be
interested in transforming this into
something else
and then
you don't want to
maybe load this data so you have this
option where you are selecting orders
and then you have something called as
enable load which can be unchecked so
when you do a uncheck what will happen
is whatever changes you perform
only those changes related data set will
be loaded and they will still be
available but this will not affect your
it will not affect your original one so
for example let's say copy
and let's go in here i will do a paste
let's say orders
oh i did a paste i need to
rename this
so let's renaming let's say orders
and here
i will say summarized
and i will say us
so i'm renaming it now let that get
loaded
we can perform some transformations on
it
so i have here
there's my country so let's look for
country
yeah
and let's look for country so here i
will go for only united states
okay that's what i'm interested in
and then i can choose well i'm
interested in just central u.s
so i can basically go for
just the central us and i can get rid of
all of these
so now i should have only central u.s
data
and this is fine and this is the data
might be we are focusing on right now
for doing some visualization might be
looking at sales
might be looking at the product
names so you have the product name now
remember you don't see any filters here
right because the filters are
coming from the resultant set and your
transformation so
if you have any filters you would be
seeing in the top row now this is the
data we have
let's uh
let's not restrict it to region region
would then reduce my data but that's
good enough for us
i can just say no
i'm clearing off this filter
i'm still looking at united states but i
want to look at all the regions
yeah whatever we would be interested in
category
and that's anyways chosen as technology
which we had chosen when we were loading
the data
we have copiers and machines
right and
we can basically keep this now
this is fine i can apply the changes
i can apply the changes based on this
one
and what i can do is i can just say for
now apply
so that's going to apply all the changes
which you have done in orders or summary
or the new one right and what i can do
is now i can choose order and i can say
don't enable this in load
so it says disabling load will remove
the table from the report and any
visuals that use its columns will be
broken we are not creating any visuals
as of now the table will be removed so
that's fine
and now i will say close and apply
so what happens is you are loading the
data based on the changes
okay now you have your
order summarized you have returns you
have scientist but you basically do not
have orders anymore so that was not
loaded so i only have this one
i only have this one
and
you have returns you have scientists you
don't have the orders column right now
that particular
data set was not loaded at all because
we did not
choose that to be loaded right now while
i'm in this
orders which is
let's see here
and actually you can drag in yeah
so you have order summary and this has
basically
kind of data which i'm looking for so i
really don't need the
orders table so you can do it in steps
and you can aggregate this you can have
aggregated data you can have all the
data which is filtered transformed
grouped by
and then basically just load it and the
original data set which you used that's
no more being loaded here now at any
point of time if i really want
i can go back to transform data and
remember
it is still here it is still here it's
not gone right so you can basically
select this and you can say enable load
and you will have the data back which
you can continue working on right so
these are some quick transformations
which really help us
in
working on the data now obviously if you
have data you want to perform some left
joins right joins
you have inner joins outer joins so you
can always do that you can take two
different data sets might be i'm
interested in taking the
orders summarized which talks about
standard class consumer shipment wise
sales
and here if i look at order summary i
have other details but the thing is we
need to make sure that these have the
values
these have the values say for example
the segment column here
and the segment column here can really
be used to join these two tables so if i
create a relationship
or
if i create a join i can basically merge
the data so this is how you work on data
we will also see some more examples on
might be modeling the data using some
expressions to work on the data so we
already looked at creating a report
selecting particular fields
and then publishing the report onto your
power bi service now this is the report
which we had created which says state
order id sales and then i also added
this returned field and that was
basically by creating a relationship
between order and returns which we can
also have a look in model so this is the
relationship which is created if you
just place your cursor here it tells me
that we have a relationship between
order id of returns and order id of
orders and that basically allows me to
join the data bring it in my one report
now this is basically your data sources
you can look at and if you click on your
visualization so that shows you your
report now what we can also do is we can
make it interesting now we would not
want to
scroll through the fields to see
wherever or what was the
order or what was the order id which was
returned
now i can do a sorting i can filter out
what i can also do is i can use this
option which shows slicer here and that
basically allows me to work with this
data so we have this
report here and basically as i said you
can click in here it shows the data now
what i can do is i would want to filter
out information or slice the information
using your returned
either being yes or
having a field which has no value how do
we do that so basically i can drag and
drop the returned
here as a field which comes from returns
now that basically shows me only the
value is yes but i do know that there is
there are some fields which are blank
now how do i add filter to this so i can
click on this one
and
then i can click on slicer now once that
does so it basically pulls out all the
different values so you have either yes
or you have the blank field for returned
so what we can do is we can select yes
you will see only
the orders and their ids and sales where
the products were returned so that gives
me 108 000 118 and i can select blank so
that will basically get me
all the orders or products which were
not returned now this is a simple way
when i can add a filter to or a slicer
to my report to basically
give
viewers a choice of
selecting different fields and you can
add any number of slicers you can
basically say
i would want particular kind of
information so for example if i go into
orders and we know we have the state now
i do have the state information here and
basically i can
if i would be interested i could filter
this out in my report itself i can sort
it
i can look it in a different order what
i can also do is how about
bringing in state here and basically
dragging it here
so that gives me the state option it is
giving me a visual which is basically
giving me a geographic location of all
these points so yes that can be good
what i can also do is i can keep this
which basically shows me the state
map
might be it can be useful you can zoom
in you can zoom out you can look at
specific information here you can drag
and drop here so that's fine what i can
also do is i can
again take the state
and bring it here
and that
basically can be instead of my map i can
go for slicer so that gives me all the
values here and which basically allows
users to choose the fields
or the states which you would be
interested in looking at so for example
if somebody is interested in looking at
the data for georgia just select this
one and you see the map automatically
shows you where in the map that's the
place
and it shows me all the sales for
georgia state now i can also basically
select yes and that shows me which were
the orders which were basically returned
so that gives me a quick overview of
statewise what is the geographical
location
if the orders were returned or maybe i
can just click on blank and it shows me
the non-returned orders
i can again go here and uncheck the
georgie option and that shows me all the
states now once you have done this this
looks like a comprehensive report which
can be useful for the viewers for your
management team and so on so we can just
do a save and that basically is saving
my report so i have this report now what
if i publish this report
so i can just do a publish
and when i publish it says okay
workspace so let's say select
and then it says replacing this
data set may impact two reports you
already have a data set named by this
one
view the impact i would say replace
or i will say
view impact so that basically takes me
to the power bi service because
sometimes we may have some reports which
we have already uploaded and
updating an existing report might
basically affect
my existing report
so it basically shows me the impact
analysis it shows me one workspace there
are two reports they are they have not
been added to dashboard but these are
the ones which will get modified so
let's for example
as of now go ahead here and let's look
into my power bi so go back to your
desktop and i'll say no i don't want to
replace so click on cancel
so i do not want to publish it or it
might be what i can do is
i can try saving it as a different
report so let's say save as
and now i will basically say
additional
filters
okay let's save it
so now you see the name on the top
changes to additional filters and now
it's
safe to publish this
and now i can go ahead and publish it
select your workspace
and basically it says this is the report
being published with our additional
filters with a map which gives a
geographical
area showing us the information and then
basically what i can do is once it is
done i can
look into my power bi service like we
did earlier you can do a filtering
we can basically query this data we can
share it with other users who might be
interested in looking at this particular
data now this says it is done so it says
get quick insights and might be it's a
good option to
look into what kind of insights it's it
gives you so click on that
see the beauty of power bi where it
tries to search for
any kind of insights which it can gather
from the kind of report which you have
built
now once the insights are ready it will
let you know what we can also do is
we can come in here click on
view data set
so you see now it shows your additional
filters
and here you have
option
where it should be showing your report
so let's say view and view is fine
so
and if it doesn't show up
sometimes it might be taking time for
refreshing so you can always go here and
then you can click on your report
and that should get populated
so this is the report these are the
filters which i have
gives me an option of choosing all the
states
and basically allows me to edit the
report and
look at all the information here
meanwhile we can see here it is still
trying to gather some insights from the
data
and now you see there are some insights
here so it says sales which is coming up
and a subset of your data was analyzed
and the following insights were found so
you're looking at sales by
ship mode so it says standard class
second class first class and same day so
there were different shipping modes in
our data and that's what it shows me the
sales which one had the majority it
shows me the profit so which city or
state had
more profit so new york city has
noticeable more profits here
average by shipping cost by sub
categories so there are these different
sub categories which we can look at such
as copiers and machines have noticeably
more shipping cost
profit by product name
and
you can basically look at the row id and
quantity so this is where you're looking
at a regression analysis
you're looking at row id and quantity so
there is a correlation between row id
and quantity so these are two different
variables or fields which are related
you're looking row id by category
row id so it says california has
noticeably more row ids sales
your profit count of region and count of
returns
so there is a correlation again between
two different variables
average of shipping cost now we would
have taken lot of time building all
these visualizations
but power bi has already helped you in
gathering all these insights and then
you can basically select which one of
these is what you are interested in you
can focus and look for more information
based on all the fields it has given you
good amount of insights which will help
anyone who is looking at this particular
report
so that's your quick insights here
and
we have this information
now
once you have this information this is
basically
where you have your focus mode so it
says subset of your data was analyzed
following insights were found you can
basically say download
and
here you have other options which allow
you to work with your power bi so
let's look at this one so this is where
we have our report and
we can continue exploring it more
one more interesting feature which power
bi has other than
having your insights ready to use
which is basically in your workspace and
you can basically use these insights
what we are looking at various options
here
and basically you have this option where
it says spin the visual if you are
interested in a particular
insight you can always spin it which you
can always go back and look into what
you can also do is you can
also click on edit report here now
that's a report which has already been
published
to
your power bi service not yet shared but
that can be shared or that can be
subscribed now once you click on edit
report
it has option of reading view mobile
layout
you have basically an option which says
basically
options for navigating through the data
set
you can go for
how visuals on the canvas interact with
each other
you have all these options and one of
the good options is ask a question so
you can always click on ask a question
and that basically
says
some suggestions now you can open this
and it says
okay ask a question about your data try
one of these to get started what is the
average sale
sort orders by order date sort orders by
product id
how many ship modes are there compare
quantity and discount so do not worry
that your report has
only four fields so it has state order
id sales and returned
with some filters but what about
you looking at how many ship modes are
there so it is already looking at your
data so if you click on this one here
and you can see what are the different
fields what we have and you have ship
date and ship mode so this is one of the
fields which it is showing you to ask a
question now what you can do is you can
say how many ship modes are there let's
click on that
let's ask this question it says four
ship modes and do you want to add this
to report yes you can you can let it be
as it is so you can basically keep this
question here
and here you have an option the visual
is showing number of ship modes
when you place your cursor here
if you
see here turn this qna result into a
standard visual
and let's do that and basically it is
saying
number of ship modes
right so now that's the power of your bi
power bi which has basically allowed you
to ask a question and quickly
add a visual to your report now what we
can do
is we can basically save this
or you can say save as and give any
different name so might be i'll just say
save because i would want to have this
information and the report is saved so
in this way you can basically not only
create smart visuals
you can not only relate
different data sources using data models
or relationships you can add maps you
can add filters you can add quick
questions
you can basically just go here and say
for example
you would want to
ask a different question now we see the
fields here how about looking at the
shipping cost right so here i can say
um
what is the
[Music]
highest
shipping
cost and that shows me some suggestions
let's select that and that shows me the
value
which is great
and i can keep it as it is i can
basically convert this to a visual i may
want to keep the question because might
be this question was asked
and
you would want to see the result here
might be you can move this somewhere
here
and that gives me some kind of question
which was asked and we can do a safe
and that's my report which has been
saved in my bi service the data set is
still there you can basically go ahead
and share this
now when we talk about data modeling
one of the things which we are
importantly talking about is the
relationships now when you talk about
your
relational database world in symbol
terms what we can understand is
that you normally when you talk about
data modeling you have a facts table
and you have a dimension table
so let's quickly understand what you
mean by your fact table or what we talk
about table which has measures or which
can be your calculated values and then
you also have your dimension tables
which are holding your data so for
example you have
a dimension table now we can understand
that with simple example so this
dimension table
might have say
five columns
let's take a simple example so let's say
we have a customer id
we have the name we have the location of
the customer
what products the customer bought
and
the country of the customer so here you
can see the customer id that would be
the primary key column
which is basically uniquely identifies
the data here and this is what i am
talking about
as a dimension table
now i can have then
specific data for product table
so that would basically have more
information or specific information
about different products so here do we
have the products which are in the
customer table which basically talks
about what are the products the customer
bought and here i can basically have a
product id
so that's the primary key column for
this table
and then you have your product
description which is basically the
product name
and then you can say the product quality
high quality low quality
and probably the price of the product so
this is one more dimension table now you
could have
another dimension tables which could
have a link to this table so when we
talk about your
schema and if we want to understand data
modeling so there is what we call as
your snowflake schema and your star
schema so when i say star schema in
simple words it could be understood that
you could have multiple dimension tables
in this way
and then you have a facts table which
basically has information so i could say
there is a customer id here
you have your product id here
might be you have something else which
talks about location id if you have a
specific table for
the location which is based on country
so you have location id and then the
country name
if that's one table so you have location
id
and then you can have some measures or
columns which are nothing but calculated
values so when i say calculated values
might be it is quantity
might be it is tax amount and so on so
you have
basically relationship so this is your
primary key and you have one
relationship here
you have product id you have one
relationship here you have location id
you have one relationship here and
probably this one also relates to a
particular column which has a relation
so this becomes your fact table and
these are your dimension tables and
that's what we mean by
your star schema in simple terms where
you have a direct relationship between
the dimension tables which basically
contain the data
and your facts table which contains the
measures now dimension data can have a
lot of
values which could be
a unique or could be duplicates now that
could again have
your fax table facts table could have
repeated values so you could have
product id and location id and same
product and location id but might be
that belongs to a different customer id
so you can have different entries so
that's your star schema now if you talk
about the other kind of schema then that
is your
snowflake and snowflake basically means
that you have another dimension table
but that is not having a direct
connection with fact table so for
example here i am talking about products
and then this particular product
is related to a product subcategory so
might be i have one more
column here which talks about sub
category of the products and here you
have the table which has sub category id
and then you have basically details of
that particular product might be it is a
luxury product might be it is a consumer
product or whatever it is
so
always when you have the main key so
these becomes your primary key and here
you are talking about your
foreign key concept or say for example
you have
these as your foreign keys because this
one or your product id is basically your
primary key so you could have
these columns which can be taken so
if you have in simple terms either you
have a star schema
or you have a snowflake schema wherein
your dimension tables are then connected
to other dimension tables but some
dimension tables have no connection
between fact and dimension so if you are
pulling out information which is about a
product and a sub category of that
then you would have to connect your fact
table with dimension table so this is in
short
brief about your data modeling which we
need to understand when we are defining
relationships now we can have our data
sets which can be coming in from
different sources we may want to connect
them so that we can access the data from
both of them
and then we can basically have a
consolidated information so what we can
do here is let's look at an example
so other than our regular data let's
load some interesting data now here i
have a scenario
where i was using a different tool but
then we are investigating or we are
doing some threat hunting now you have
the data which comes in from different
sources so let me just show you that so
for example if i look into
the data here
and this data set or these set of data
sets i'll show you the github link from
where you can download all this data set
you have to just go ahead and type say
bot sv1 data set and you have basically
the full data set which can be
downloaded which is huge or you have the
attack only data set now this has
basically your windows event logs it has
firewall related events it has dns or
http
and you have other data here so this
data can also be used to basically
join your different data sets and create
a relationship because what we know is
the data might be coming in from
different sources but then it has
certain fields which
have a connectivity between them so we
can use one such data set or couple of
data sets so if you would want to
download this you can
directly download these attack only data
sets
or what you can do is all these source
files are available as json
or also as csv source type that's where
i got the data from so you can use this
so for example if we have the data
coming in here and say i have data
coming in from firewall that is
fortigate you have data coming in from
http stream or http dns
you have windows event log and we can
take up these data sets and see how we
can basically use them now say for
example you are searching for
the http data and then you would want to
find out how many source ips are there
or how many destination ips are there
and then what kind of information it
contains so
let's start with some data set here so
for example let's say get data
i will use excel i will get into the
data types i can choose all files and
let's go for the first one just to play
around with this one let's see what does
this contain now this is a huge data set
fortigate event that's mainly for
firewall related data so let's open this
now obviously the data is huge it shows
whatever we have based on first 200 rows
which we see there is a serial number
there is a time
source
what is the protocol which was used
what's the source type you have host you
have index you have splunk server and
then you have the raw events which are
all in one column which obviously we can
split and create different columns based
on our requirement so before we do a
load of this data let's go for
transformation which brings our power
query editor now we have the serial
number
are we really interested in this so i
would say
probably not so i will just go ahead and
remove this column so time is fine you
have time which can be then split as per
time zone you have source you have
source type which we know it is coming
from fortigate event i can keep that
just in case i would later want the
information to be understood
i have host i have index now this is
where the data is coming from and i
don't need this
so splunk server let me get rid of this
and then i have the raw data which we
have seen earlier but let's go ahead and
split this because if you just double
click on one value it tells me that it
talks about the time it talks about an
ip address it says date it has a device
name device id login id
type so it basically gives me sub type
it has
user statistics and all this so let's
play around with this one and i'll break
this or split this so what i can do here
is i can go ahead and select this and i
can choose split and i can go by
delimiter now delimiter can be chosen
and i see that there is space as a
delimiter and i calculated if i look at
the event i can divide that into nine
different columns but rather than going
by delimiter i'll go by positions
and
it basically says these are the
positions you can anyways change the
number so it says something at 16th
position and then 30th position and so
on so you can do that
you can just say okay now what does that
do it has basically replaced my data
with
different columns now that's based on
the positions so then we can basically
transform it in a better way so for
example i have these two which says
august and fifth but let's see if we
have any date field here which says i
have it talks about august 5th it talks
about the time so what i can do is i can
actually get rid of this one
so
i can say let's choose this let's choose
this
and let's go ahead and remove these
columns so that's gone so you have time
you have ip addresses
and
let's basically look at this so i have
this time i have the date and then i
have time again so let's select this and
this and what i have noticed or i have
seen already that the time what you have
here and the time what you see here as
the event time is the same so let me go
ahead and remove these columns too so
that's also gone now we have the date as
the column so i can remove this one and
what i can do is this one i can rename
as date so let's choose this let's give
it a name let's call it date and that's
your date now this one is your time so
let's change this to time
and
we can make it time so that's done now
here i have the ip address so for
example let's just call it
let's just rename this and let's call it
ip
address
so that's also done
now let's see what else we have
so we have a host ip here
and then we had an ip which shows up so
i do have this and basically these
values should be same
so what i can do is i can in fact get
rid of this one also
remove this so date is fine time is fine
you have host
now these are your device names so let's
basically
give a name to this column so i can say
rename i will call it device name
and that's fine what we will also do is
it will be easier to check so we can
replace this so i can say replace values
and let's give this pattern so i'll say
device name equals and i want to just
remove that so let's say okay and your
device name is gone
similarly you have device id let's do
the same thing so first let's rename it
to device id so that's my device id and
here i will replace this so i will say
replace values
and let's say device id
equals has to be replaced or should be
gone
so that's also done
now you have your login id so let's get
rid of this column
so
i will remove this and then here i have
i think it should be log id or login id
so let's rename this and let's call it
log id
so that's also done
now
we can change this data types so we have
some raw event here which says type is
event sub type is system
so
we can split this again so let's take
this let's do a split
and let's call it by say delimiter
so i can basically split it with
delimiter
and that's going to create
four columns if we use equals
or i can go for position for example
let's go in here and let's try doing a
split
and this time let's go for position
and here
it gives me some positions so let's say
okay
so it's giving me some error please
enter a value so let's say
uh 4 5 9 10 let's say 10
and let's say 11
and then you have a space
so let me just choose this and check how
it works
so you have your subsystem type
which is fine
but then i lose my event so i don't want
to lose anything so let me cancel this
let me cancel this okay
and we have the data here let's say type
is event system is subsystem
and
i can basically have the information
here but then
let's go ahead and ignore this because
this one would not be really used in my
search so i can in fact remove this or i
could have said
type and it will have event sub
type will be system but that's going to
remain same so let me remove this column
now again i have raw format which talks
about level what kind of information it
is is it information is it notice you
have root id you have log description
you have interface so let's go ahead and
split this one so let's do a split
let's go by positions
and
we have the positions here so let's for
example
take
position of the characters here
so for example the first one could be
you have 5
and 6
18 so let's say 18
and then let's go for
other values so that's again your
let's go for say 28
and then we have 28 and 7 35 36
36 and 5 41
42 and you have
46 around 52.
so let's go for 52.
so what i did was the last column which
we had which we were splitting by
position so we can basically split based
on positions or the number of characters
but then
sometimes in one bit of information you
might have indefinite number of
characters so choosing the
splitting based on characters or
positions might be inappropriate what we
can do is we can do a splitting and i
can go for delimiter and this time in
custom i will instead of custom i'll go
for space
which should basically consider every
space as the delimiter it automatically
identifies the maximum number of columns
which will be created is 13 we can
anyways get rid or delete some of those
which we don't need so let's say okay
and it has done the splitting so now you
have all this as level so let me rename
this so you have to work with
transforming your data before that can
be loaded in the way you want so let
this be level and let's also replace
this like we did earlier
with level
equals and then replace it so that
becomes your information on notice now
this is your vd
which is
related to your login so for example
let's keep this so i will rename this to
v
d
and then we can basically replace all
the values here so let's call it vd
equals
and then replace it with nothing so that
gives me the root user
i also have
the description here which tells me
where is this information coming from so
let's rename this to log description
and then once that is done we will also
replace the values so i'll say replace
and i will go for log description equals
replaced with nothing
so that gives me log description here we
have interface or action
so this is what we have which basically
has some values now if i go into the
filter
it tells me it talks about the count or
it talks about the interface or it talks
about status so there are various fields
now we could keep it as it is and we
know that there is this delimiter so
let's just call it type
and
that's enough so now you have the total
which talks about the count or cpu
so we have
messages
right how many times it was used what
kind of statistics it is right and we
have a lot of information here which we
can use
and we can filter this but
it depends on what kind of information
i'm looking from this particular data
set i'm really going for
something like totaling or something
like
cpu count so you always have these
filters which tells me okay if you are
looking for
what kind of messages you have what kind
of information you have so let us have
that as it is
this one talks about
your action or it talks about your
message and so on so i would not need
this
so let me remove this one
then i have message which talks about
statistics
it talks about total sessions
so either i can focus on the message
or i can look at how many sessions were
there
so that's something which we can look at
and we can
do a filter so for example
i can say text filters
and let's say
begins with
and let's
say
either you have
message begins with we can choose one of
these so either i could say total
session
or i could keep
message or i could keep ips so i can
have
specific kind of data so let's say yeah
so let's do one thing first we will do
some filtering here so first i will say
replace
the values
and i can basically keep it as message
total sessions and ip address these are
the three things i would be interested
in
and rest of the things can be
taken off
so what i will do is here
i will say
unselect all then i will go for action
is login action is log out
i can look for the ip
values
i can look at message values
and then you have your total sessions
so if you are really looking for a count
of total sessions
or we could have
split this data filtered it out and
created different columns out of it
so
let's go for because message we already
have so let's go for total sessions
so here i will basically say i'm only
interested in
begins with
and let's say
total session and i will just say i'm
interested in total session values
let's filter it so that gives me
total sessions
and if you see here it might affect the
kind of information what you are
collecting
if you are
using this particular filter so let's
keep it dynamic let's clear the filter
now i do have information about your
disk
your bandwidth
not interested
your setup rate
so let's take this let's take this let's
take this
let's take disk log rate i will remove
these columns
then i have my
other information
message performance statistics not
interested remove these columns
so i have
my list of columns now we do see that
the user is root here in most cases
so vd and what we can do is we can
remove this because if it's all column
values or common values we don't need it
log id
it's not relevant
and i have filtered out my data with has
date
which has time
device name device id ip address
what is the source type so this is we
will keep this which can be useful and
now we have our timestamp here which
basically has
the data but we have date and time
which is
given here
so we can either keep one of these or i
can keep the time column so that i can
sort it out based on time or based it on
dates so let's choose this
and this
which is
6 28 this is in a different time zone so
let me get rid of this one so i'll say
remove
now
that's basically the data which i have
looks good
which we can use so i will say close and
apply
and
that's applying my changes now this is
one simple data set which we took from
firewall
and which has
particular fields so you see there is a
date field now date field is basically
you can look at the date hierarchy you
have year quarter month day and you can
choose work on it so you have some raw
fields and we can rename those so we
will see that
so we have our data which is getting
loaded
and that's your cpu
which we had
we have the total sessions which we are
seeing here
okay and we have some systematic
information let's also go back here home
and what i can do is i can go into
transform just a quick
run through the data
so we have the eyepiece host
log description now these are my raw
fields which talk about the type
which talk about the total
and which talk about the messages so
let's give them some name rather than
keeping
so we can call them
this is type let's rename this and let's
call it
type 1
info
let's call this one type 2 info
and then let's call this one type three
info
today
why remove the column sorry yeah so type
two info and then you have
type 3 info
type
info
and
so you see we had some raw data or data
coming in from logs but we have
transformed it let me just do a close
and apply
and that's my one data set which we have
which will have these fields if you see
the names
right and it shows me the kind of
information we have now depending on the
filters so you have these different
filters i can select all
and it shows me all the information i
can unselect these and i can say okay
i'm interested in
looking at the information where i p is
2500 and let's select that
and basically then it gives me the kind
of log description messages what is the
type of info and again in this i have
just interface information
in this i'm seeing
dhcp message right so i can remove the
filter but then my filter works
perfectly fine so this is the data i
have
and
we are good to go with this one so i can
basically save this
if this is what i'm interested in let's
call it something so let's say
photogate
event
report
save it
and that's
basically the report which i have saved
with this information although we have
not done any kind of visualization on
this
so this is good now let's take a stream
http data and work on it and we can see
how we can connect these so for example
let's go in here
so let's select all files so we took
this data now we have a traffic data it
would be interesting if you would want
to look at the data before because then
you would know
what data can be collected so if you
look at this data which is in a csv
format
looking in excel so it's trying to read
that
and then we will see what are the fields
which we can use to map different
information so you might have
some firewall information about an ip
you might have the traffic information
you might have the dns information you
might have the attack or the malware
information and all that information can
be joined together by we creating a
model which can have a relationships
and then basically
create visualization which relates to
the data coming in from different data
sets
so you could do a join you can
have multiple data sets and you can go
for a left join right join you can merge
different data sets you can do that but
data modeling does make your work easier
where you can have your facts and
dimension tables you can basically have
more meaning to it so it says file not
loaded completely that's okay we will
filter this now if you see here
this also has a host information
it has time
and it basically talks about server
and then you have your raw data which
basically is
your timestamp device id what we were
seeing
and then you have your login id like we
had in previous example right and then
this is basically the traffic
information so if i
basically take one such field here i
could see what is the kind of
information it contains
it gives me the traffic information
what is the source protocol right so
this is my one event which i'm looking
at it tells me
what was the
transaction ip what was the transport
port what was the service which was used
is what it was a microsoft portal which
was being used uh what was the
application risk
what was detected how many bytes were
sent
how many binds were received right so
this is basically giving me some traffic
information now we might be able to use
this if i really want to see from one
particular source ip
if you look at the source ip here
and to the destination ip
how many bytes or how many packets were
sent and that might be something which
we want to query or visualize and find
out if there is
basically huge amount of data flowing
out or flowing in so we can take this
data so
looks interesting so let's not save it
and i will go ahead here
and what i will do is
this is my
one data set so let's go in home
let's go to get data
excel
let's go in here
i'm looking at all files
look at the traffic data
open
obviously that's huge data so we want to
transform this we can even limit the
number of rows or select particular ips
which we would want to look at so as we
did last time let's remove the serial
number
not needed time we will have in other
fields so let's get rid of that
source is fine source type is fine host
is fine
index not needed
your server not needed
you have the raw data which has to be
basically split
and this is the data which we have now
we can select certain important fields
here so let's go ahead and do a split
and let's go for positions
and if you see it identifies the
position
it basically knows that there are these
positions the values are at these
positions which we can then merge
or say for example i could have gone
simply by space
so if i say let's go in by split columns
by delimiter
let's choose space as the delimiter
let's say okay
and that basically gives me
columns
so
let's go in for this one august this one
we will see if we have any time field so
we don't have any time field as of now
this is what we have we have date
we have time which can be merged
together if we are interested in so what
i can do is i can remove these columns
right so it becomes so easy with power
bi where you're working with bigger data
sets although the data is in structured
format but even if it is not you can use
all these things to basically split the
data now here we have some timing
so let's get rid of this one
let's remove this one so there is
repeated information
you have host and this one let's remove
this
because all the information in a raw
format is stored in one particular
column so you have date
and time so
we can keep the date and time together
we can concatenate it
we can basically merge it and make it
one so
let's say first let me
replace this
so i will basically go ahead and rename
or let's say replace
and i'm going to replace all the date
equals with nothing so that purely gives
me the date and this one is time so
let's replace everything with time so
time equals
and then replace it with nothing and
then i choose this and this
and i do a merge
and let's call it separator let it be
i can give a colon or i can give a comma
or i can give a space space looks good
let's call it date and time or let's say
it's just a date
so that's my data looks good so you have
device name
you have your
device id like what we had so we don't
need this one which we deleted so let's
get rid of that
so type you can always see how many
values you have so if it is type is
traffic
let it be so let's quickly replace
this one with device name
and then basically go ahead and
oh i did a remove but not to worry i can
just cancel this and i have it back
so now i can
replace the values here and let's say
device name is replaced with just the
name
similarly this is device id
so let's do that device id and
we will still do a replacing here so i
will say replace all the values
and device id equals is replaced with
the actual value
now type is traffic let that be it's a
type of information which might be
useful for us
so let's go ahead and rename this and
let's call it type 1 info
and here i will replace
all the values of type equals
there should be multiple other simpler
ways of doing it you can transform the
data using a programming language you
can do that so this tells me there are
some subtypes which are about
because we are talking about the traffic
data so it says subtype which is forward
or local now that depends on what kind
of information you are searching for but
let's keep this so i will rename this i
will call it subtype might be we can
take this and keep it in a different
column or different table altogether so
we can do that
so subtype and let's say replace
the values here
subtype
equals is replaced with just the value
then you have the level you can see what
kind of levels you have it just says
notice that's the only one value
so let's get rid of this one
let's get rid of this one
now you have the source ip
you have the source port
which can be very useful information so
let's rename this and let's call it
source ip
go ahead and replace the values here so
let's say replace and i'm going to say
source ip equals is replaced with
everything so that's gone and now you
have your source ports which could also
be important so let's go ahead and
rename this let's call it source port
and
let's
replace the values
source port equals and that's basically
gone
now we can go further we can look at
the source and what is this kind of
information so here it tells it's a
source
of
internal source port what we are seeing
and we have some internal or some other
information so there might be
various other messages but all of these
refers to the same key and value so
let's rename this
we'll see how we can use all of this
information so i'll call it
int f and then i am going to
replace this
source intf equals is replaced because
we have given the column name
now you have the destination ipn
destination port very important
information so let's go ahead and rename
this let's call it destination ip which
might be just meaning ip in some other
some other data set
so let's do a destination ip let's
replace the values now
with dst ip equals
is gone
and
the same thing here
dst port
that's the name
and then replace
i could have done that easily in
excel also but then it's good to view
the data and then make the changes here
so destination port
and then you have your
this one
so
it basically has some values might be we
don't need this so let me remove this
column
and
and i will remove this column also i
don't need it
so i
till i have my source ips and port
destination ip and port which we can
even merge
with a particular column but let's keep
it separate in case we would want to
pull out the information
then you have your raw information which
says
session ids and all that so let's get
rid of this let's get rid of this let's
get rid of this
and anytime you can basically see what
kind of information it has so it has
some session ids we are looking at the
bytes going in and out
so let's remove these columns that's
gone
you have
policy id okay
and action so let's
keep these so
this one basically has
either your policy id or destination
country information and what has
happened is based on the position
sometimes you see the
destination id or country
either in this field or in this field
right so you have destination country
source country destination country and
source country so
this information
what we are seeing here
is something which has split
based on the positions what we have
so we have uh
position id
which has action so let's look at these
so we have here so we have action we
have policy id destination country
source country
and then you have these fields so what
we will have to do is if we have to
extract the values and
create this as a new column so for
example i had this
and i could basically say
duplicate columns
and then i can basically say one can
just have my policy id values one can
have my destination id values so it
depends on the kind of information we
are looking at
we don't want to lose any particular
data here but let's see
so we have action let me do one thing
let's say action
let's say
draw 23 24 test destination
source country
so you have a service which tells you
about what kind of service was used
what was the duration
you have to just make sure that you
don't have any fields which are being
missed because of the data what we have
so
well we have the
actions policy id destination country
source country
what kind of transport was used what
kind of service was used
and this is where it gets challenging
because you have lots and lots of fields
so if you see here all these fields are
nulls so first let's take this let's
take this
so you have
fields where there might be data down
the line i mean it does not mean that
all these fields so you see here there
is some data
in the underlying rows
but it depends on what is the
information we are looking for so for
now i will just choose this
we can do a lot of work here but let's
not get into everything let's do a
remove
let's just see step by step the critical
ones
and let's
go all the way here let's do a remove we
don't need this data
so here we have your application
category your collaboration
your app risk now this could be useful
so let's do one thing let's keep this
this
this because remember we have a text
filter which can be used to filter out
the data
so i can basically choose these fields
as one
transport
let's keep
this one
and we will test it
so we have these fields let's take this
last one yeah and let's do a merge
column
okay and i will basically say let the
delimiter be
either comma
which could be useful
so let's
go for comma
and let's call this
info
so that's my data which has been split
now say for example if i would want to
filter out some values i do have
something like this and i could
basically go for text filter i can say
contains
and let's go for something like
united
and now you will see
wherever your values are united states
that shows up but you can be more
specific in saying i want the
destination country
so
i can basically say
clear the filter let's go in here
let's go for text filters
let's say
contains
and let's say
destination
country
equals and let's say
united let's just search for this
particular pattern
and now you will see you have only the
destination country being united states
right so that basically allows you to
filter out the data for now i can clear
the filter so looks good
we have some useful data
and this is your traffic related data
what we have
so let's basically close and apply
and depending on the size of the data
set you can have it taking some time so
we could filter out we could have said
okay i'm not interested in
anything which goes
after or before august 19th because this
is
i think uh data coming in from 2016 2017
and we can choose the year so but let it
get loaded we can anyways do a
transformation and
we can check for information
but this is how you are basically
creating data sets which has different
fields now we can then change the data
type as i explained we can transform
this data we can basically relate these
data sets and extract information out of
it we can create visualizations out of
it
and
let's see what is the size of this data
so it tells me we have
well that's a huge data set let's say
if you see that's almost four gigabytes
so
88 yeah so it's a four gigabytes data
set might be we have to
uh
cancel
this and
[Music]
there are some pending changes but let's
just let's reduce it so what i'll do is
i'll go for transformation
and i'll do a transform
and we have these different filters but
let's go for the date
field which talks about
something and it tells me 2016.
right so we can select this and what i
can do is i can do a transform
by ear
and let's say i'm saying year
doesn't look good
so
that's only giving me how many values do
i have
i have only 2016 so let's do a load more
to see if there are many other values
nothing specific so let's go ahead and
remove this
okay so i would be interested in it's
all august 8th but then might be i can
pick up a date
which is
going to reduce the data
so we have eight one two how many
entries we have we have
say for example 24th and i know that
there is some problem in 23 onwards so
let's choose from 820 onwards
so
i'm going to
unselect all and then i'm going to say
let's go for 8 20 21 22 23 24 28
and anything before that
let's take 29 let's do a load more to
check if we are missing on any dates no
so let's go for
select all
right now you could go here and you can
say date
filters and you can basically say
the month or the day
right so is not latest you can choose is
earliest in the next in the previous
before after so if i go for after
now it tells me
you need to choose a particular date so
i could straight away say let's choose
anything which goes after 8 19
right and now you have 28
so that's basically selecting some data
so we can
then also say
if we want data for particular subsets
so for example let's choose this now
let's say close and apply
it should substantially
reduce the data now if you see here
since i'm doing a close and apply it's
trying to load
both the data sets which we have
and that might again take time so you
have to choose
once you have transformed if the data
set which remains in your
query editor if that should be loaded
when you are loading the other data sets
sometimes if you are working on multiple
data sets that might be a bigger problem
so let's give it some time and we will
check once the data is loaded
so both the data sets have been loaded
now and if you look into the
fortigate event data so that basically
has my dates and we can check that it
has everything beyond 20 as we chose
and let's look at the traffic data so if
i look at the traffic data now this one
basically has
dates which are
even before 20 so it is trying to load
the columns and it has
all the dates and what we will do is we
will try to sync the data and we will
keep it
beyond 8 20 like what we had in the
previous data set so let's
have this one selected
and let's go in here and i will say
transform
and i will go for transforming the data
again which i forgot to do earlier or we
can just reduce the data because the
data sets might be huge and once you
have prepared your model and if you have
a bigger system then you can go for
loading all the data so we have the
time and date field here
and then we have
other fields which we are looking at
but this one basically has time which
shows up
everything we can again merge this
as date and time
like what we have in our
traffic data so let's quickly check in
traffic data we have date and time
so let's go in here
and we have the date and time so let me
just bring it here and then we can
basically first
merge them so i have the date and time
but we are interested only in data which
is after or from 20 onwards
so first let me
basically
apply a filter here
so we can go for date filter
i can say after that's the easier way
let's go in and select
from 20 or let's say
let's go in here and this shows me 19
let's choose 19
and let's go for
okay
that should basically now give me only
data which is 20 and
beyond and now let's select date
and time
and let's merge this with a space in
between
so let's call separator as space
and let's call it
date
let's say okay
and that's merged
so we have the time here which is 1158
and
in rest of the fields
so that looks good to me and now let's
do a close and apply but remember
my
i'm working on event data and traffic
data was already loaded and it is a
bigger data set so i can select this i
can say enable load again
so do a continue
and now let's select this where we
really made the changes
let's do a close and apply
and that's done because this was not a
bigger data set
and now we can quickly check
so in the date fields we are looking at
the event data
so you have
everything starting beyond 820 so
anything before 820 is gone
and that's fine with us
and
what we need is the the traffic data
also
so let's go back because that was not
loaded but we really need
that so let's go in home
let's go to the transform
let's choose this it was not loaded
and
let's enable
load so let's check yes this is fine
and let's go ahead and
basically close and apply
so now it's only going to get me the
traffic data so earlier we had the event
data that was already loaded so you can
select data sets step by step and then
load them so in that case it can be
faster
you can reduce the time how much it
takes now obviously once you have
filtered out all the data which you are
interested in
and that is already loaded
then we can
basically create a data model which can
join these
data sets based on device name based on
device id based on eyepiece and we can
create a link between these
so now that the data has been loaded for
these two kind of sources we can
basically look into the fields what
these have so you have device id device
name destination ip destination port
and similarly you have the events here
which has device id device name
so we can basically get rid of some
columns or some columns we can keep them
with the same naming conventions so this
one basically has
a date dot one field
which we can change
and here we have date so
let's look at this one and i'm looking
at
the date field here
which basically says state.1
which doesn't look good so let's rename
this
let's call it date
and remember this is a bigger file based
on the time or the date or any other
filtering criteria which we have chosen
so either you reduce the amount of data
so that you can break it down and your
processing can be faster or
when you would be using say microsoft bi
that would be working on a powerful
machine which could store it now once
this is done what we also would want to
do is
we would want to work on loading one
more data set
so this is
firewall data and i would be also
interested in http data
which also gives me information of
the http different methods such as you
have have post you have request and so
on so we can do that now this date
column looks good you have type 1 type 2
type informations you have device name
which says
dev name dev id
so that looks good to me
and
let's go in here let's look into this
one so we have dev name dev id
so those names are fine you have your
destination ip destination port
you have the host name
you have the info you have source and
source
type so let's look at
the traffic data
and this is where we have your source
ips
your source port destination ip which
looks like a dns server
and you have your host ip
so you can see
what other information you have so if i
just scroll this
i have source and source type which is
showing up right here in the beginning
and if you compare this one so this also
has a source and source type
which basically uniquely identifies
where the data is coming in from
and obviously we can arrange the columns
in the way they look
the order of those we can merge and
manage them so this this looks good now
let's go in here
let's go to get data let's go to excel
let's choose
one more file
and i would be interested in http i can
look into this win event log which looks
like a one gigabyte file this one looks
like a smaller 28 megabytes file so
let's take this one and that's getting
loaded here
we would want to transform this data
okay so let's get rid of serial let's
filter that out now we can see there is
this
time field which is here but we can
split that out
so let the time
be
let's not take this one let's remove
this so stream source
host
index we don't need let's get rid of
this let's get rid of splunk server
now let's look at host information
and
that basically gives me a similar kind
of server name so let's not even use
this one
now comes our raw field if you double
click on one of these it shows me
a lot of information here
and it is in the form of you have your
data is separated by comma here so we
can basically choose comma as the
delimiter
splitting the data and then you can have
consolidated information
so let's go ahead this one let's do a
split column
let's go by delimiter
and i'm going to
choose
comma
and let's say
okay
and that basically shows me
the column so you have your
end time timestamp now these two can be
merged
and we can replace the brackets so
that's fine
you have
acknowledgement packets information
you have bytes bytes in bytes out
you have source ip which is cip
you have cached
so
we can get rid of these we can
so you see there are these number of
columns now let's work on this so first
let's
get
this
and this
[Music]
so first let's replace this so we have
everything starting with end time so
let's go
ahead and rename this to
end time
that's done now just to replace values
and what do you want to replace so let's
use this bracket let's say end
time
and colon now that one should be gone
so that looks better
we have the timestamp also
and if you carefully look at the
timestamp here so you have the timestamp
which can be brought out from this one
let's do a second level replace
and what i'll do is i'll choose anything
starts with t
i can do a wild card
ending with z
and let's
try this
and it does not find this particular
pattern okay let's do it in a different
way so i can do a replace
and we can basically say
t
should be
replaced with space
so now you have t which is gone
and we basically have the date and time
so what we can do is
it will take a little bit of work here
where you have to merge the date and
time so the easier way would be
basically splitting this data based on a
delimiter so we have these time stamps
embedded with the time so what i can do
is i can go ahead here and do a split
column by delimiter now i know that
there is a time delimiter t
so let me split by that
and now i have my
time which also shows that in a date
time format
you have end time which is also having a
timestamp so first is let's clear this
off let's get rid of this column
and now the end time i can basically
here again
do a splitting of this
by delimiter and this time my delimiter
will be
a
custom and then let's choose a dot here
and let's split it based on the dot so
that gives me the timestamp which is
automatically formatted which looks good
although we have to take care if it is
in hour or
12 hours or 24 hours format so now we
don't need this we can get rid of this
and that's the simplest way and then
basically i can do a merge of
this
and this
let's do a merging
with a space as the delimiter so let's
call it space and let's call it date
and let's do a merging
in simple way we have the data here now
the time and everything can be formatted
but that gives me some information
it tells me packets in packets out by
its
bytes
bytes in bytes out
and we can basically club this
information so i can basically say
your acknowledgement packets so if you
see here you have acknowledgement
packets in so these are the only values
which you have and we can
get rid of
all these values which says accept and
accept so we don't we are not interested
in this we are interested in
acknowledgment packets in and out
and that looks good
so bytes we can look at the filters and
it basically gives me all the bytes
value let's keep that so you have bytes
in bytes out
now these we could have basically
filtered out and given column names so
like we did earlier so we can just do a
rename and let's say acknowledgement
packets
in
that's going to be my column name
and then let's just replace the values
here
which is basically going to search for
ack underscore packet
underscore in
colon should be replaced or should be
basically gone
so let's get rid of that
so it's still working on it it might be
huge data
and similarly we can work on this one to
do a replace and let's call it
acknowledge
pack underscore out
let's choose
this column let's do a replace values
and we want acknowledge
packet
out
colon should be replaced with space so
just the values there and we have given
the fields right then that should be
fine so let's get rid of this overall
bytes
we would be more interested in looking
at bytes in and bytes out
so let's go in here and let's rename
this to
bytes underscore in
and then
basically
replace the values or you could keep
that with a key value pair if that's
what you would want to keep so bytes in
with a colon should be replaced
so that works fine so this one is still
taking time let's see
we did a replace
and we said acknowledgement
packets out
that was the pattern
replace it with nothing
yeah so now it's working
and then you basically do a replace you
have to be careful with the
case sensitiveness
and let's replace this
oh it doesn't look good
so let me again do a replace and i want
the semicolon to be gone
yeah
and bytes in similarly you have bytes
out
so let's say
bytes underscore out
and
replace this bytes underscore out
and then you basically have your client
ip
which shows up here now do you want to
go for caching no
do you want to go for capture host name
not exactly client rtt client packets
client sum
let's get rid of these
so that's gone so connection type which
basically has you can always look at the
values which says
connection type close or keep alive not
interested
this version not interested
so basically we can
if there is a lot of information which
you might be
uh using later so you have some data
packets in data packets out
and let's see we already had here bytes
in bytes out
yeah
so let's go in here and let me
do this thing so before i work on the
client ip let me take this take this
take this
all this information here
and let's basically merge these
and we can keep
comma
as
separator and let's call it info
so that's merged
and then you have data packets in and
data packets out so let's quickly rename
this
so
before doing that just check the values
here so you have
data center time
now we have the time factor already and
it talks about data packets in and out
and that's basically in
values or out values so we don't need
the data center values so let's go ahead
and
basically
get rid of this
so now the data has been transformed i
have basically replaced the client ips
and all the other data which would be
better if we keep as one so this remains
because this has embedded information
and we don't want to lose any data so
it would be good to keep it here and
then we can do a content search on this
so this is the data which has been
modified
now i already had these data sets so i
can basically choose
enable load
i will remove this
i will basically go for this one which
is enable load
and then i am only interested in this
one so let's do a save close and apply
so the changes have been made now these
changes will be applied now if you see
my older data sets are already here and
i really did not want to go through the
whole process of reloading them so i
have just worked on this stream http
data
and i am just loading this one so
this shouldn't take much time
and we should have the data loaded now
once we have this now similarly you can
work on all the data sets so i do have
the source source type you have the
dates and if you closely see here all
the dates is basically beyond and it's
only 8 28. so
i do have information but here i am
looking at
the date field and that basically shows
me all the fields here so
looks like we have to filter out the
date because that can again be whose
data it tells me there is 21
758 rows
there are columns with these many
distinct values so it gives me this but
let's do a last level of filtering
so i am going to work on transforming
this
so
[Music]
let's go in and transform this one again
and here you have the date
and we were interested only in 8 20
onwards
so let's make sure that
this is the date we have
okay so best option would be first
basically splitting this
so let's go ahead for split this
by a particular delimiter and here
my delimiter will be
space
and then we can
re-merge the data so this is
being split date one and day two
now
i can go here and
it does show me only these dates but
let's make sure so i'll say after
and we will look into
oh i'm sorry so what we are doing here
is we are
removing this let's not split this this
was actually fine because i was looking
into the event data which is fine we
have to focus on
this one so this is where my
date
has
it looks to me in a
date string format which is not good
so let's do a split
by a delimiter
and let's say the delimiter b space
and let's say okay
so i know it will
basically have these two so it basically
has split the data and now what we will
do is we will go in here it shows me
yeah so it looks shows me all the dates
which we are not interested in
we are interested in only
these dates
well i could have said after and that
would be an easier approach
yeah so this is fine now we have the
dates now
we have applied this filter
so let's take this
column and this column again
let's
merge the columns
let's have space as the delimiter let's
call it date
and let's say
so we have all these values now this
column which was also extracted from
here
could not be merged so let me remove
this
so we have to spend some time in doing
this data wrangling stuff and now let's
do a close
and apply only for this http data
and now we only see the stream data set
which is available here first let's
confirm
so we have
successfully transformed our three
bigger data sets
one is
http related and to our traffic and
events now this is how the
as of now there is no relationship
between them if we would want to
visualize the data which comes in from
one source or joins with other source we
will have to create relationship between
them
however we can look at the fields and we
can try to understand so let's look into
the data set
quickly now if we look into the event
data so we have our source source type
we basically have the host
we also have the date and time which is
there in each of the data sets so you
have
basically
the date here
which we can see in traffic data so we
have the date we have event that also
has the date however the format is
little different and what we can do is
we can basically look at the data we can
we can see that it is in
a text format and if we would want to
change we can do that however date is
not the concern
the
other fields have been transformed so we
look at total number of sessions we look
at the type of information
what kind of information we have what is
the kind of device id
so this is what we are seeing in
event
now in traffic
i have
my host name i have the date i have
device name device id
and these device names and device ids if
we look at
the other one
that is event
so these would be same
and
then you have other information which is
related to traffic here so you look at
the source ip you look at the type of
information and then if you look in
stream http you have packets in packets
out bytes and bytes out so let's
basically now
create a visualization taking the
information from all these three now we
can either
explicitly define relationship or when
we are creating the visualization we can
go ahead with the
relationship so
let's go here and let me
first choose
your
stream http so i have the client ip
i have the source and source type
so what i will do is i will basically
say for example let's start with
your event and traffic data so let's
have a merger between these
so let's select event
and here let's select
the date column
so let me bring the date here
now that basically gives me the date and
the time
and
that basically looks fine now you also
have your device id so let's bring the
device id
which shows me the device id let's bring
the device name
so this is the information i want now i
can get the source
so that i know
where all the data is coming from
so let's take the source and drop it
here
so that basically tells me the source
i also have the source type so let's
choose the source type which tells me
event
and then we basically have say for
example
type info
that is the field i have
so for example let me select type 1
bring it here
and that tells me
what is the kind of information i have
either it is a count
or basically it's an action which we can
basically then create some filters to
filter out the data let's look at type 2
info and that basically gives me type 2
info which is either talking about cpu
or
total count
so let me just get rid of type 2 info
that doesn't look so interesting
let's look at type 3 info
and that basically gives me some total
session and dh dhcp statistics so we
will
just keep type one info here and now
i will choose the traffic traffic
and here i will choose the destination
ip
so let's bring it here now when i do
this it says cannot display the visual
fix this let's go ahead and fix this it
says
do you want to do a auto detection of
the result let's do that
so it basically says there were no
relationships which were detected let's
go to manage relationships
and since there is
huge data it has to basically
you have to give the control to power bi
fill up the field so it is basically
showing me
the from table name and to table name
and
if we have some relationships which can
be created
so
i can click on
new and here
let's choose event which basically
has the host
device name device type and so on
and
here let's choose traffic
now
i have basically the device name
and that basically can be chosen and
device name can be chosen here and i can
say
this shows as many to many relationship
and if you see that this relationship
has cardinality many to many this should
only be used
if it is expected that neither column
that is device name and device name
contains
unique values so if it has unique values
then you can go for one too many
so we can basically go ahead here and
say one to one for example
but it says it is invalid let's go to
one to many and again it says so the
only which is expected is many to many
and
choose this
so it basically says there is a
relationship
established between device name and
device name
i can also say new
again choose and here choose traffic
so we have device name also so let's
select this our device name is already
done so device id
and then device id here
and let's make this active
or i could have just said okay
so let's say okay
and now you have device id and device
name
let's also see something else so let's
look at new
and i will choose event so i have all
this information which is
giving me the type of information what
we have total number of sessions what is
the performance statistics and all that
but then these might not have the same
columns here
so what are the same columns we have
so we have
traffic we have source ip
we have source port
and then we have information which we
would want to pull out
but let's basically
go in here and we can define a
relationship between source ip
and here we have the host ip
so
if we know that this is the host where
we are looking at
so for example if i choose host and if i
choose source ip
now
i can say
okay
so these are some of the relationships
i'm creating
and
then i can
you can't create a direct active
relationship between event traffic
because an active set of indirect
relationships already exists between
these tables to make this relationship
active set the cross filter direction to
single
delete or deactivate any of the indirect
relationships first
so we have direct and indirect
relationships which we can choose now we
have
if for example i remove this and then if
i select this so i'm saying let the host
and the source ip be
my relationship let's click on close
and now let's see
let the data get populated
so based on the columns which we have
chosen and now we are interested in
the
information here
so let's look at the model meanwhile so
you see the kind of relationships you
have created
so there is basically
your destination
so you have the star symbolizes many to
many so we basically have many to many
relationship and that basically depends
on the column names which we have mapped
now if i go back here
and this is where i can be seeing so
let's go into traffic
and let's drag and drop the type one
info here
and we will have to give it some time
because now it is trying to detect based
on the device id device names it is
trying to match
the value
of your source
which we have chosen here with the host
information
and those values have to be same because
that's the relationship we have made
active
and then we will see the result because
it has to basically filter out
the
host name
here
and you have the
source ip
which we chose here so let me go back to
the relationships
and that's your device name device name
this is your device id device id this is
your source ip and host
let's go back to visualization
so since we have established the
relationship i can select this i can
delete this and i can go for
visualization again so let's now
go ahead and start selecting
say for example date field
now i will choose the device id
let's go for device name
device name
let's make this bigger
and then let's go for
source
i would want to keep the source so it
tells me
what is the source type
right we can get rid of source for now
source type is fine
and let's also go for
host
so that basically gives me my host
values and we can
just to check
since we have linked our host with
the source ip
in the relationship
let's also choose destination ip
source ip
and finally your
type info
now this is basically huge data what we
are looking at
so
it is basically
saying filters on these visuals which we
can basically control
so here if you see you can do a sorting
you can add some list
so right now we have added these filters
and we will have to give it some time
where it can populate so meanwhile you
can either do a show as stable
you can go in here
and then
scroll down
and you have data fields here filters on
the page which we can apply now let's go
to the drill through
so let's go to the formatting
and let's go to the grid
and
you want to have vertical grid so let's
switch it to on let's make it
black
and now i have basically
your horizontal grid color so let's
create that also as black
now we can go for font size so let's
increase that
that's your text size
depending on your screen
and image height that's fine now column
headers
you can look at the font color what's
the background color
text size let's make it bigger
and then you have your values
so this is fine and now you have your
totals if you have
field formatting so we can choose
the date field which we have chosen
and we can choose this
which basically says do you want to auto
align it or you want to change something
you want to give a title so these are
all the options which you can use for
formatting
and let's go in here
and let's go to the filter here
so remember it is going for
my when you look at the filter it is
telling me these are the host ips which
it will be looking for
this is the source types it will be
looking for this is the source ips which
it is looking for
and we can either select
one of the source ip
depending on the count what we have here
to filter out the data
or it's going to be
trying to match all the entries here now
we are looking at a bigger data set
so let me choose
here
a particular value for example there are
three entries for this particular ip
being the source ip and we have type one
info we can see what kind of information
it contains it talks about traffic
now that's what we wanted based on our
host and source ips
so this looks good we just need to make
sure that the host field
was connected to source ip
so let's go in here and select
let's search for something
so there is a 250 entry here
okay we can come back to the visual
let's go back to the table here and
let's look at some data
so we are looking at event let's
look at the host value which is 192 168
that's my host
and here let's look at
in traffic
let's look at
the source ips sorry the source and then
you basically have the host
which has the same values
so
host and source ib so what we created as
a relationship might be we have to
basically check that
so now that
using the relationship what i also did
was earlier we were creating multiple
relationships and that can also slow
down the process so what you can always
do is you can go back here and if you
see i have created a relationship
between host to host because i know the
values
can be sync in sync or same across these
so if you would want to work on a
relationship you can just go ahead and
delete this
and that's basically
gone
so your relationship is gone and now
your visual report
if you go back will show that there is
some error because there is no
relationship established
now let's look at the fields again so we
have
this particular information which is
saying that
we have our
data set so let's look into the stream
http data set
now this is where we have
basically packets in packets out
so we have the source
and source type which basically are
giving us the same information
so we can choose one of these in http
and then you also have your date you
have packets in packets out bytes in so
you have total bytes now this is what we
can focus on
or we can be looking at
what is the total number of bytes bytes
in bytes out so this is the information
coming from http
now again you have the client ip here
so your client ip has 192 168 250 100.
so basically let's try to match that
here now when you look at the http
traffic
and if you look at destination ip now
that's the basically server so you can
always see what are the kind of values
you have
so you have different values here
and this is where the connections have
gone
you have your source id which is
basically
showing up
different values again so you have
different source ips
you have different destination ips
and you have the host name which is 251
that's your only host name in this one
in the traffic
now if we look at type 1 info then we
are looking at these columns now since
the data is huge you don't see these
other columns but then we can obviously
refresh and we can see if these columns
are showing up so you have
more number of columns which are here
which will be used so you have source i
b you have destination ip and so on
and
if we look at the information
from your event you basically have
your source
you have your host
so let's take host device device id from
here
now we have the level let's see how many
values you have so you have alert
information notice warning so we can
then filter out only warning messages if
we are interested in
so i could be just saying warning so we
can choose level from here
we have your log description which talks
about kind of statistics what is the
info so is it performance statistics
and then you have your cpu total
sessions so now
for example let's go to visual
and if i would have to create a
relationship i will have to choose
different fields now the only one thing
which we need to understand is in stream
http
you have your client ip now let's look
at those values here
stream http
which basically has your client ip
let's look at the source
and also we can work on the date
field here
so this is in am or pm
what values we are seeing
and let's have the date field in
event
that's also showing am or pm
so let's first create a relationship
between hgt and stream http
and what we can do is
let's keep it here
let's bring it here
so what i can do is i can have from
stream http
a relationship with the date here
so there can be date now there are these
formats which we can change if that is
giving a problem
let's say okay
however it is advisable let me just
delete this
let's go back here
okay
so we
want information from all these three
data sets
and we do not want to really go with the
join condition we will basically want to
join them either on the date field or
basically your other fields which have
common values
so since there were
many relationships created and then we
had to look into the fields which had
date time format in a different way what
i did was i did some cleanup i removed
the relationships as of now and we i
reloaded the data so just let's look and
understand that
so this one starting from our three
different data sets first let's look
into the event
by clicking on this now it shows me
source type
it shows me the host
that is from where the request is
originating it shows me the date look at
that format here
and then you have device name device id
what is the type of message and then you
have some log information based on which
we can filter out or pull out some
specific information now what we notice
here is hostname is 250.1 and we have
only one
host field
so that's perfectly fine now let's look
into the other data set that's
traffic
which will give me some traffic
information
now here again if you look at the second
column the host is 251 which basically
means i can create a relationship
between
event and traffic based on host
field now notice the date format has
also been changed we have device name
device ids so that also should be the
same values
and you have the type info so you can
look into what kind of information you
have and this is traffic information
it looks at
the sub type and that tells me either it
is forward or local on which we can
create filters now you have the traffic
going to the source ip
and you have the source port so source
ip basically has different fields
and we will see
what is the source ip so you have a host
and then you have source id
from which the connection would be going
to say destination ip so you have
destination ip which have multiple
fields
and then obviously you have info wherein
you can say for example
select
one of the fields or just place your
cursor here and tells you what kind of
information it has it has an action it
has policy id it has destination country
source country and everything is
separated by comma so if you would want
you can split this complete information
into comma into different fields so
that's your second data set
and the third data set is your stream
http
which basically has your source type it
has the date again format converted
packets and packets out and here you
have client ip which is basically
showing
let's look at the values and it has
various values now the source ip in the
previous data set and the client id here
from where the request is originating
would be the same one and then obviously
you have the information so now we can
create a visualization using these so we
have
the model here now what i can do is i
can start creating relationships between
this one so here i have host
and i can have host connected to host
here
so basically this
has
now what does it say this should only be
used if it is expected that both the
columns do not have unique values but we
know that there is unique value which is
192 168 250.1
so if i say one two one
it basically says the cardinality you
selected isn't valid for this
relationship if i basically go for apply
security filter in both the directions
it does not still work and you can look
at the cross filter which says single so
you can have a relationship between
this and this
so
you can say but the thing here is there
are various combinations for these
particular values and that's why it is
saying
this cardinality does not work so let's
go for many too many
that's fine and let's go for okay so you
should have a relationship now between
host
and
your
host now what we can also do is we can
go for device name or device id
so
i can again create one more between
device name and device id
in case there are different values
i can say okay so this is one more
relationship i am creating between these
although i am not making this active so
we can see
when we look at the star it tells me
that it is many to many
now what we can also do is as i
explained so you have
your traffic
which basically has your source ip
and here you have client ip so let's
create a relationship between client ip
and source ip
and
let's go for okay
so that's again a relationship between
these now these relationships should be
enough for me to pull out the
information from all these three data
sets
which can be related on the same date or
which could be
based on the values so we do have date
what i have done is i have filtered out
the data as i explained earlier
which was 20 onwards 8 20
but then i have changed that
to make the data set a little smaller
and i have chosen anything beyond
8 23
and then up to 828.
so now this is done let's go to
visualization
and let's
pull out the information so let's say
it is talking about
a previous field which we have let's
close this
so i can say fix this
and here i can close this one so we
don't have any data fields right now
so now let's start selecting so let's
first go to event i will be
interested in the date field
and let's get the date
now it is broken down into your year
quarter month and day now we can change
that format so here we have your date
field
which is basically being
broken down now i can just say date and
i don't want the date hierarchy so
date is fine which gives me the time you
see the starting time is 23 onwards
now what we are interested in is
basically the device name so we have
created a relationship and it is good to
choose
the fields on which you have created the
relationship
now we have the host field
so let's select that now there is one
entry for that and that shows me the
host field
you have level which had two values so
let's select
ho level now you can always check here
when you are looking at these particular
fields you can sorry check here which
will tell me what are the different
values and if you want only a selected
value say for example we want
warning information or
basically alert information which is a
lesser number i can select that or i can
add that as a filter so i can do that
so let's for example
choose this level so that's done now
let's go to the traffic field so we have
date we have device id we have device
name which we have already taken so
there is no point in taking device name
again
we can look at the destination ip
so that's available from this
data set let's take the destination ip
now host is something which we have
already created a relationship
we have info we have source type we have
source ip
so let me go for source ip from here
and i'm adding source ip now i have
the info field which basically has the
overall text which has useful
information which we can pull out so we
have chosen the destination ip we have
chosen the source id which we can do a
count on and then basically we have say
type one info
which basically has
some specific fields so let's try adding
this and we can see what kind of data it
contains
and that might be a larger field so it
might take
sometimes time but then that's okay
and
[Music]
that's your traffic that's your event
and now we have our http data so this
one basically has your client type which
would be same as host ip as i mentioned
earlier so let's select client
ip it got selected twice that's fine and
then you have your info as the column
you have bytes and bytes out you have
acknowledged packets in packets out and
you basically have your source type so
we can select source type just to keep
in track of the data is coming in from
which source but as of now i can just
choose bytes
in
which might be interesting field to look
at
if there are bytes coming in and then
you look at bytes out
so let's for now cancel this type 1 info
and this is the data which we are
creating the visualization now as i said
when you are selecting these particular
fields it is going to
look for the
host ip
it is going to look at my destination ip
now we can always go back to the data
set and check
if what appears in host ip does that
appear in
say source ip or client ip in a
particular data set so for example if i
go in here and if you see i have client
ip which is basically
192 168 250 100 that's what i have
filtered
for
in this particular stream http data set
so if you go back to client ip
that's the value which is showing up
and if you look in traffic
so here we have our host or we basically
have our
destination ip or source ip so let's
look at the source ip and here i can
search for
the ip
which we see as client ip so let's see
and then let's search for 100 and that
shows me that there are entries for this
so it basically
is correct where we have created a
relationship between source ip and
client ip we have pulled out this
information now let's go back to the
visualization it is still working on it
based on the data what we have now what
we can do is the level which we were
seeing here
so level which basically had
four values and we see there is a
least count of alert so let's choose
this
and that should basically
faster or make my query faster because
now i am selecting for
your
filtering and i am saying level is alert
so it has to
not look at all the information but it
has to pull out level being alert and if
you see we already have these entries
which basically tells me host ip
and then you have source ip and then you
have client ip which is same so source
ip and client ip are same what was the
bytes in what was the bytes out right
and now you have the alert level so this
was
the alert where we were saying we also
look at the destination ip and it pretty
much looks the same
except
the one which we see here
so
this one where we are looking at the
information on 23rd august it tells me
alert where host is 251
you have source ip which is basically
2.50 we have client ip which is matching
and then you basically have a
destination ip
wherein bytes in is zero and bytes out
is huge and this is something which we
can look at to see if there is any
problem with that so this is a symbol
report which we have created and what we
have is
we have these
different levels what we are seeing i
mean we have chosen alert as the level
now what i could do is i can add
a filter
so or slicer so it says the entities
that columns in the values bucket belong
to are not hierarchically related
because then we can look at the details
here so it says
value bucket or not so we can send
something or
for example we can get rid of the filter
as of now let's just go to the table
and we can basically say okay this is my
level field
so we have selected just this particular
data but what we would be interested in
is not information but might be notice
or warning messages so let's also select
warning
and then obviously we can do a count
we can find out
on this information what we are pulling
out so i would want to look at my alert
and warning messages
when
your source id
and client id was same
request was originating from host
and we are looking at bytes and bytes
out but i can
now look at specific other information
so if you go back here and if you look
into your data set so we have basically
our data set which shows the source ip
because there that was the filter which
has been
applied now i can basically go ahead and
say clear filter here
and that shows me all the entries it
saves me
it shows me what is the action which
says accept or
information so we can do a text
filtering here where we can be looking
at different values so let's see what
kind of values we have here
and if you carefully see
it tells me
that there is this destination country
which is canada
and your destination country is hong
kong source country something else
so we can be looking for a particular
country we can be looking at
if you look at the dns apps what is the
app here
is it a dns is it a net bios
is it something else
what kind of risk we are talking about
is it elevated risk are we talking about
duration
so we can filter out this information to
reduce our results because as of now we
have everything so
say for example i have my
destination country as netherlands so
let's go ahead here and i will basically
say
let's go for a filter
and let's say text filter let's say
contains
and now let's say i'm interested only
netherlands data
so let's say okay
so the filter is applied and now what
you're looking at is just the
netherlands data for your
particular data set come back to your
visualization so
we see the information getting populated
here
and we have alert we should have the
[Music]
warning messages also
as we have chosen so we are seeing alert
as of now
as the level and we look at a lot of
destination ips now similarly what i can
be doing is i have this information i am
looking at the level which is alert now
as i said we can be choosing warning
like we chose earlier now what we can
also do is we can pull out
the information which is based on the
total bytes
if we would want to see so let's
basically bring
total bytes field
and that should get added to your visual
and now you see
you have the total bytes values which
are showing up for all your entries here
now that's my symbol report which we
have created based on the fields we can
be
just looking for
your
source ip and client ip being same so we
have chosen host because we were
interested in getting the
data from our respective data sets
that's your
event
which basically has some log info so now
i would be
interested in getting the
bytes in or bytes out so let's get rid
of bytes in
that's not what i'm concerned about i
would be interested in looking at the
log info
which is basically a consolidation what
we can also do is we already know
what is the destination what is the
source ip what is the client type which
we are looking at and we know that
source ip and client ip will be matched
so let's reduce the burden by
getting rid of your
client ip here now if you see we are
already seeing some information
which has come in here which talks about
your log info
which talks about configuration was
changed who was the user what what was
the ip
and we are basically filtering out the
information i am still seeing
the source ip i am looking at the client
type
i am looking at the values where they
are basically matching
so you look at
the new data which is host name you have
le alerts
you basically have your destination ips
source ips so we can always see what is
the destination ip what is the source ip
source ips same as your client ip
remember the bytes in byte out
information
what we are extracting is coming in from
your stream http data
and these are
if you just look at the message it
clearly tells me that this is a alert
message
and that's why we are seeing
configuration changed now that's the
kind of information we are seeing and
there was a alert generated which was
coming in from source
and on this particular destination
server
so this was and there were some bytes in
bytes outgoing and you can look at the
total number of bytes which is a total
of bytes in and bytes out so you can
also calculate what was the bytes in if
there was some kind of acknowledgement
which was sent and this is good
information so we can get rid of alert
and let me say just warning so i would
want to select warning now we are
talking about count of 400 and we will
have to give some time and then we can
start saving this or publishing this
report what we can also do is once we
have published the report we can ask
questions to this one
right so it will always be good to
publish the report with all the levels
rather than
a particular level because then it gives
you a wide variety of asking different
questions different kind of log
information messages
what we are seeing at so date can be
important
device name what we are looking at can
tell me where the data is coming in from
so technically speaking we have bytes in
bytes out that's the kind of message
which we are seeing
and we are
seeing what is the device name now
device name
is basically coming in from
this particular event field and that's
why it is showing up the values here we
don't have any device name
so
we can keep the device name or we can
filter it out
so we know that there is a relationship
between host
of your photigate event and fortigate
traffic
and that's good enough now i have taken
up this example which looks complex but
then it's very useful in real time
machine data where you can create
visualization where you can work on
multiple data sets where you can do data
modeling which basically means
that you can have relationships between
different data sets so that you can
create your visualization you can create
your reports and then basically you can
save or publish those reports so once
this report is generated based on our
these simple data sets we can
continuously improve our data modeling
so right now we just have
this information but what i can do is
i can go for
the modeling option here
and then i can basically
mark as date table i can manage the
relationships here i can go in for a new
table new measure
so remember measure is something which
you can create here so these are your
dimensions or values coming in from
dimension tables so new measure is
basically if you would want to calculate
something
if you would want to calculate something
so for example you want to calculate how
many different destination ips are
existing
or
if you would want to go for a quick
measure so choose from a list of common
calculations and add the results to the
selected table so we can do that so for
example let's go for quick measure and
it says
okay what is the calculation you would
want so it says
you can get a average per category
variance per category
you can basically do a count you can get
max so max and minimum would not work
might be we can work on bytes data
so we can do that we can say
basically your quarter to date total
month to date total so you can just go
for
total for category so filter supplied
and you can basically go for cat
totals you can do some mathematical
operations if you are interested in you
can concatenate list of values so for
example we can go for
total for category now calculate the
total across all values in a category
applying filters in your report so we
can basically say what is the data field
you would want to work on
so for example let's say the
destination ip
so let me add that here
now this one
is category over which do you want to
calculate the total total
so i have destination ip and let's say
source ip or client type so that's the
category and i'll say ok
now this is where you are doing a quick
measure where there are list of measures
which we can add so measures if you
remember
dimension tables are something which
contains the actual data
and your measures are basically what is
stored in the fact table right so fact
table has fields or columns which
are
already in your dimension table
so
your dimension table has the columns as
the primary key and facts table has the
columns as the
foreign key
plus your fax table will have measures
and basically those measures is what you
are trying to calculate which can be
added to your table that is as your
report and then you can publish the
report so this is where we
chose a quick measure we are doing it
now i can add a new column i can create
a new measure depending on the value so
what i'm trying to do here is i'm trying
to say
let's find out the count
of your source ips
and the category which i'm choosing is
destination ips
so i would want to get a count of
what are the different source ips what
are the counts of those and then we can
basically tabulate that so let this
report run and we will have a view at it
and we will then publish this so now if
you look at this
messages so we are looking at
our report might be
quite big in a format
so i can basically choose the format
by going in here
and we have the general and background
and let's look into general
so
it basically gives all text
we can give some details here
but let's look at the grid
so first let me
it is still working so sometimes you
have to wait
so for example i choose
and then i look into the value so i can
go into the style and i can change the
formatting
so
the report which we are running is on
huge data set
and that's something which we need to
remember
to basically look at the result
or to look at the count of whatever we
are doing
it might take some time
but then once it is done we can easily
publish this so after sorting the data
and reducing the data because data was
really huge so it was taking time to
generate the report and publish it
so basically here the report has been
created now we can apply measures to
this
if you closely see here i have applied
filters which is alert
which basically tells me just 12 alerts
because we have run a quick measure
so i am looking only for alert level
information and date i have chosen
everything beyond 27 754 because what i
know is
that in my
traffic related data so if you would
basically see here
in the traffic related data so we have
date which has been filtered
and if i look into my other data such as
http
[Music]
i can see the date which exists
here shows 26 because now we have
filtered the data so you have to filter
the data otherwise you might
fall short of memory now here if you see
the data starts from 28 23 51
and then that's the last one so you can
obviously see in a reverse order or you
can sort this by doing this and that
should show you the starting data
and here if i closely see there are all
the fields
which are showing up but then you can
basically choose how much data you are
pushing in there so the data here is
basically
having huge amount of data and that will
affect your visualization so you have to
be careful
in what data you select
and how much
would go into your visualization so in
my visualization
based on the fields which we have
selected i have
basically limited the amount of data
which can show me in the report however
when we have a bigger server we can
basically create a report with all the
data
or the suggestion would be to break the
data sets into smaller chunks and then
go for reports and visualization now
this report was published to my bi
service and if you see here this is my
bi service which has the data i have
applied the similar kind of filters here
and now i can start asking questions
which can then be added to my report so
here i am saying show me the first
total of this cp
total from
your s source ip so i can look into
something like this now if i'm not
interested in this i can delete this
i can ask different questions here so
for example
count
i can say count destination
eyepiece and that shows me there are
different
13.44 destination ips
and i can say for
each
source ip the resource ip or the client
ip now you can give
a query like this
which will basically try to do a count
of destination destination ips for your
source ips
and it can give you a count so here it
gives me
what is the
destination ip for each source ib and
this one has
the highest count and then you can look
at the other values and if you would
want to save this
question
or the answer to this question let's put
it here so we can basically
make our report layout
a little smaller
or change the format here
so that
we can push in more data here or ask
more questions now once this is done
i have my report created with different
kind of filters i can just go ahead and
save this report
remember i have filtered out the data
and i have selected the data fields with
date being
just for two days instead of for two
years now that basically affects my
overall data but what we have seen here
is we
are looking at
our report now what we can do is
we can look for
other information here so we have the
visuals on the canvas we can duplicate
this we can share this
we can look at the view
and we can change this we have the file
and we basically have our reports which
is shared now if i go back to my
workspace
that shows me
the dashboards which i have i have some
reports now this is the report here
and
this is basically you can look at the
usage metrics you can share the
information you can get some quick
insights which power bi is very powerful
in looking at your data and gathering
some insights however again remember the
amount of data which is selected will
affect the time consumed in generating
these insights so
while this is running i can go back to
my power bi desktop and
i can basically have a look at this i
can look at the data models now these
were the relationships which we created
so if you see this was basically host
and host
this was device name and device name
and here i had the client ip and the
source ip and this was basically my data
model now i could have a facts table
separately created with the columns and
then the measures which we can calculate
and then add it to our facts table now
this is basically a simple example of
data modeling you can play around with
the data as i mentioned you can
obviously
go to
power bi and if you would want to look
at this data as i mentioned earlier you
can just search for bot sv1 data set
generally these data sets are used
for threat hunting but then this has lot
of
data sets with different sources and you
can get the data from here you can trim
it and then you can basically use for
your power bi or you can always find
data sets and
you can look into kaggle or other
sources where you can get different kind
of data which can be used now if you see
here
it basically gives me some insights and
we can choose which
insights we would be interested in so it
says count of the source ports
and basically it gives me that
these ips or which i know these are dns
servers have noticeably more source
ports
it gives me count of total bytes and
count of bytes so this is a correlation
between total bytes and bytes it gives
me count of info so
what kind of
information we have on packets in so it
says that there is lot of information
with packets in being three
now i can scroll down i can see count of
source report and count of info
so you can basically look at count of
total bytes count of info so power bi
has generated all these insights for us
and we have this information now i can
obviously download this
so i can basically go in here and look
at this particular insight i can open it
in a focused mode and look for more
information
and we can choose what we would want to
do with this insights so if you see here
it gives me
when you look at the info what kind of
messages are more that also gives you
information total bytes count of
your destination ips and i can
basically click on this one it opens up
in a bigger window it tells me this is
count of this type is or sorry
destination ips based on your source ips
and
this is a great insight so you can
always look into the insight and then
basically
work continue working on this so i can
just do exit focus mode i'm back to my
insight i can go back to my workspace i
can look into the reports now remember
when you publish your report
your report comes in here and that
basically gives you
an option to create a report
you can schedule it to refresh and get
the newer data
you can basically
view related information of this
and so on so this is how you can use
modeling with power bi and this is a
simple example well we can have
more complicated modeling
uh modeling scenarios and we can look at
different data sets in this video we
will learn what power bi dashboard is
you'll understand how to create
different reports in power bi desktop
then you will publish a dashboard onto
power bi service and finally you'll
derive insights from the dashboard now
let's understand what power bi dashboard
is power bi dashboard is a single page
visualization to tell a story here on
the screen you can see there's a
dashboard which has been published on
power bi service there are multiple
charts and graphs that you can see the
visualizations on a dashboard are
generated from reports and each report
is based on one data set a single page
dashboard is known as a canvas the
visualizations you see on the dashboard
are called tiles and each of these tiles
are pinned to the dashboard by report
designers today we'll be covering the
following dashboard that you see on the
screen it will be a three page report
where we will be analyzing the
superstore sample data as you can see
there are three tabs now let me move
over to our data set so our super store
sample data set is in the form of an
excel file you can see there are
multiple columns you can see there's
order date shipment date the mode of
shipment customers first name and last
name the segment to which the customer
belong to country of the customer the
city state and if you go towards the end
you can see that the different product
names the sales quantity sold discount
and the profit so the report that you
see here and the one which we are going
to create might vary a little in terms
of the color formatting and the spacing
so you need not worry about that now let
me go ahead and bring up a new workspace
so i'll go to file click on new this
will take some time to bring up our new
workspace
now it will ask you for trying the free
version or if you want you can go ahead
and sign in i'll just close this so here
is our new workspace before creating the
dashboard we need to make some changes
to our superstore data set using the
features of power bi desktop first we'll
extract the year month and quarter
values from the order date column i'll
go to get data tab click on excel as my
source i locate my file it's on desktop
click on open this might take some time
to load the data set i'll select the
orders sheet you can see the preview of
our data here i'll go ahead and click on
load this will take some time to load
the data set on to power bi desktop i
think we have successfully loaded our
data set you can check that by going to
the data tab so here is our data set
first let's make some changes in the
format of the order date and the
shipment date i'll click on the order
date under the modeling tab
we have this data type and the format
i'll click on the drill down option
under date and time now let's choose the
first one which is in the format of ddm
yyyy
i'll click on it
as you can see our order date column has
been changed to that particular format
similarly i'll select the ship date
column
go to the format option under date and
time i'll click on the first one
here you can see even the ship date
column has been changed to that
particular format now let's extract the
month values from the order date column
to do that right click on the order date
column
select new column
so this will create a new column if you
go to the end
so there's a new column
rename this column as month and since we
want the month value from the ordered
date column i'll search for order date
dot since i want the month i'll select
month if i hit enter
it will give me the month values from
the order date column
similarly if you want to get the quarter
values from the order date
right click select new column
rename the column as quarter
then choose the order date column
followed by the quarter
name hit enter
so you can see you have a quarter column
and it has all the values of the quarter
to which the date belongs to now let me
go ahead and create one more column
this time we'll create a new column for
the order year this time we'll extract
the order year values so let me rename
it as year we'll continue with the same
procedure i'll look for the order date
and then select the year
hit enter
so it gives you only the year values on
which the order was placed
now let's find which day of the week was
the order placed so we need to use the
weekday function and give the order date
as parameter followed by which day you
want the week to start with i'll show
you how to do that so i'll click on
order date
then
select new column
let's rename this column as day of week
i'll use the weekday function of power
bi can hit tab to finish i look for my
order date column
comma
i'll choose 2 here since i want my week
to start with monday and end on a sunday
hit enter
so you can see we have the day of the
week column
so the idea to create this day of week
column is to find out if the order was
placed on a weekday or a weekend now let
me go ahead and create one more new
column
let's name this column as
we day
or a weekend
i'll use an if clause
and pass in my parameters for logical
test i'll use the day of the week column
so i'll search for orders
and then look for day of week if this
day of the week is equal to 6 which
means if it's a saturday
or i'm using the or operator
if the day of week is a sunday that is 7
then it's a weekend
else it's a big day
close the bracket
hit enter so you can see we have our big
day and weekend column so moving ahead
another thing we can do is we can find
the total number of days it took for the
shipment of the product this can be done
using the date function of power bi so
let me show you how you can do that i'll
click on any column right click go to
new column let's rename the column as
days
for
shipment then i'll use the datedif
function
i'll give my starting date which is the
order date so i'll search for
order date
followed by the second date will be our
shipment date which is ship date and the
day
i'll hit enter
so you can see here it gives us the
total number of days it took for the
shipment of the product now let's create
a full name column where we will
concatenate the first name and the last
name of the customer let me go ahead and
do that
i'll create a new column
let me rename the column as full name
then i'll take the first name
from the orders table
use the amber send
followed by a space using inverted
commas followed by another ampersand and
the last name
i hit enter
you can see we have a full name column
if you go back so there were two columns
in the name of first name and last name
now we have merged both the columns into
a single column named full name and you
can see the first name space and the
last name now let me give the sales
column
a currency value so i'll select the
sales column
here
under general
if i go to currency i can see there are
multiple currency symbols
choose whatever you want for this video
i'll take dollar english united states
you can see our sales column is now
represented by a dollar value similarly
let me make some changes to the profit
column as you can see there are multiple
decimal values for each profit so let's
standardize it
so i'll select the profit column
and this is where you can standardize it
now it's auto so let me
make it two decimal places
so our data is ready now let's go to the
report view and start building our
reports
before that
under the model view
you can see the new columns that we had
created you can see there's weekday
weekend this year
this quarter column month column
the same
you can see under the report view as
well
under fields
you can see these are the columns that
we created days of shipment day of week
quarter
month weekday or weekend and year now we
are under the report view first let me
go ahead and create a text box
so under the home tab you have the text
box
i'll select that
let me stretch it a bit
we'll give a title
sales
dashboard i'll select this and increase
the size to
let's say 28 we make it bold
and
center align it also
under the visualizations tab under
background
will add a background color to this text
box let me select this blue color and
let me make
the font as white
so now we have our title ready
so under general you can decrease the
height of the text box let me make it as
70.
first let us create a new card from the
visualizations panel so under
visualizations there is an option to
create new card i'll click on it
let me resize
i'll move it to the top
we'll see the total amount of sales or
the total revenue that was generated
from the sales
after selecting the card
i'll choose
sales onto fields
so here you can see it gives you the
total sales that were made so which is
nearly 2.3 million dollars
if i go to the format tab under data
label
let me switch on the border
under title
you can give a new title for example
total
revenue hit enter
now you can
increase the text size to say 15
and center line it you can also change
the color of the
sales value so under data label
under colors you can choose whichever
color you want
similarly let's create one more card to
find the total number of units that were
sold i'll copy the same card
ctrl c ctrl v
i'll move it a little below
now i'll remove the sales column
from the fields and add the quantity
column
on to fields
again
under title
i'll edit this title as
total
quantity sold
let me create one more card
where we will see the total amount of
profit that were made
i'll select this
i'll remove the quantity column
and add profit
under the format tab
under title
i'll make this as
total
profit
hit enter
stretch it a bit so that you can see the
total amount of profit that were made
now
let me add a slicer
wherein
we'll have the order date column
so i'll add the order date column onto
fields
so you can see here we have the order
date column
and
under slicer header
let me increase the text size
to 15
and
let's switch on the border
you can also give a title to the slicer
so under the format tab
go to title
switch it on
and we'll give a title text as
slicer
by
order
date
scroll down
i'll center align it and
increase the text size to 15.
now if you want
you can also change the date colors
to blue so under date inputs then go to
font color and select any blue color
now let's create a line and stacked
column chart to visualize sales and
profit by each year each month and each
quarter so from the visualizations tab
let me select line and stack column
chart
i'll resize this
after that let me add the order date
column onto the shared axis
we'll drag the sales onto column values
and under line values i'll take the
profit column
so here you can see we have the sales
and profit by each year
the bars represent the sales and this
line represents the profit it made for
each year
let me go to the format tab
and
make some changes to the data colors let
the color of the profit remain the same
but the bars i'll choose a custom color
give a hexadecimal value like
hit enter
so we have successfully changed the
color of the bars
power bi has an interesting feature
where you can drill down the sales by
each year each month each quarter or by
days so let me show you so on the top it
shows you go to the next level in the
hierarchy so if i click on this
here you can see the sales and the
profit that were made for each quarter
in every year
quarter four for every year made the
highest amount of sales and the profit
similarly if i drill down further you
can see let me expand it you can see by
month
this is
for each month
over all the years how much sales were
made
you can check november month gave us the
highest amount of sales and
december month gave us the highest
amount of profit
similarly you can still go to the next
hierarchy here you can see
the sales and the profit made for each
day
over all the years so days 17 made the
highest amount of sales
and day 23 gave us the highest amount of
profit if you see the lowest sales and
the profit you can see ordered date 25
gave us the lowest amount of profit
and similarly you can see day 29 gave us
the lowest amount of sales
now you can also go to the format tab
and switch on the data labels
so you can see here
in 2014
we got nearly 49.5 k profit and nearly
0.48 million dollar sales similarly in
2015 we had nearly 61.6 k profit and
0.47 million sales and so on
let me go ahead to the format tab and
switch on the border let me now create a
clustered column chart for sales by year
and quarter so from the visualizations
let's select clustered column chart let
me resize this a bit
and
under access
will add the year column
so i'll drag here on to access under
legend i'll take
the quarter column
and under values i'll choose sales
so you can see here the sales that were
made under each quarter for each year
this picture clearly says quarter 4 for
every year made the highest amount of
sales and quarter one
made the lowest
let me go to the format tab
and
i'll go to the data colors let's change
the colors for each of these quarters
we'll be using hexadecimal values so
under custom colors for quarter one
let me select hexadecimal value as
follows for example pf
d6
d9
similarly for quarter two
i'll select
6d line
basics
for quarter three
and finally for quarter 4
i choose a little darker color
so here is how our clustered column
chart looks like and we can see the
sales by year and quarter
now let me go ahead and
let's add a border now
we'll analyze the sales by each state so
for that
will use field map so i'll click on
field map
let me resize it
now let me add the state column onto
location
under tool tips i'll
add the sales column
let me expand it so you can see here we
have the map which shows the sales by
each state
now let's do some color formatting to
this
i'll go to the format tab click on add
colors
and blue is the default color there's an
additional option
where you can use conditional formatting
so i'll use that
so it gives you the option to choose
your color between maximum value and the
minimum value you can also choose this
diverging option where you get a center
value or a mid value as well now for the
minimum value
i'll choose a color again i'll use a
custom color
it will be similar to a green color
hit okay
then
let's use
some orange color for the mid value
range for example
eb
and similarly for the maximum value
we'll use a little darker color which
looks similar to red
click enter so now we have
defined our color scheme
let's click on ok
let's zoom out so you can see the states
which are in green color make the lowest
amount of sales while those which are in
orange or in red made the highest amount
of sales so in this example you can see
california had the highest amount of
sales similarly new york is next it's
just below california with the amount of
sales followed by taxes we'll go back
let me
also
add a border to this similarly
you can also select the profit column or
the unit sold column to see the units or
the profit that were sold by each state
so let me now go ahead and create a
donor chart in that donor chart we'll
analyze the sales and profit by each
segment
so under visualizations i click on donut
chart
so under legend i'll add the segment
column
under values i'll take the sales column
and
we also want the profit so i'll take
the profit column on to tooltips
so you can see we have our donor chart
prepared and you can see the sales and
profit by each segment
let me expand this the donut chart
indicates consumer segment made the
highest amount of sales and profit
while home office segment made the
lowest
i'll go back
let me go to the format tab
and we'll make some formatting to our
data
let's change the color of
all the segments
choose custom color
let's give a color
coding as
1558c
similarly we'll change
the color for corporate segment as well
let's take a gray color
and finally we'll change the color for
home office as well
i'll also switch on the border
so we have our donut chart prepared now
let's move ahead and create a pie chart
to analyze the profit and sales by each
category of products so under
visualizations i'll select pie chart
i'll drag the category column on to
legend
under values i'll take the profit column
and under tool tips i'll take the sales
column
so you can see we have a simple pie
chart that tells you the profit and the
sales that were made by each category
as its evident category technology made
the highest amount of sales and profit
while furniture category made the lowest
amount of profit and sales
i'll go back
under format
i'll change the data colors
let's go ahead and do that
i'll use custom colors and give
hexadecimal color value
similarly for office supplies
i'll take another hexadecimal value
and finally we'll change the color of
the furniture category
also
let's give a border
so we have a pie chart prepared that
tells you the profit and sales by each
category of products
now we are done with our first sales
dashboard so i can go ahead
and rename
this tab as
overall
sales
next we are going to analyze the sales
profit quantity sold and all of these
by taking region and the state as
filters so we'll continue with the same
drill first i'll create a text box
so under home menu i'll go to text box
i'll stretch this
i'll give a title to this page for
example
region
and
state
level analysis
let me make it bold
and
i'll increase the size to 28
make it center aligned
we'll make the text
as white
and
under visualizations
let's give a background color
i'll choose this blue color
so let me go ahead and create three
slicers a region slicer a state slicer
and a ear slicer
so under visualizations i'll click on
slicer let me resize
move it on top
and
for region slicer i need to add region
onto fields
so you can see
we have a region filter now
let's do some formatting to this
under slicer header
let me make the font color
white
and let's give a background
let's say blue
and let me increase the text size to
say 15.
you can also choose a font family
let's go for calibri
and
you can increase the size
of the items
let's increase the text size
to
say 15
and
let's give a border
so now you have the region slicer ready
let me copy paste this
next
we'll create the state slicer so i'll
remove region from here and add
state onto the field
you can see we have the state slicer
ready similarly
you can also go ahead
and create
a year slicer
where you can analyze the sales and
profit
or quantity by year
i'll remove state from here
and
i'll drag the year column on to field
you can see we have all the four years
from 2014 to 2017. now sometimes it
might be difficult for you to scroll
through all the values present in a
slicer for example
in the state slicer
you can see there are multiple states
and if you want to filter your report by
a particular state
you have to always scroll down or scroll
up and check manually where the state is
so power bi gives you this feature where
you can use the search option so
if i click on this
you can see there's a search option
select that so now
in the search bar you can search for any
state you are looking for for example if
you want to search for california state
you can just type on california so i
have just typed cal and it shows me
california that's an important feature
that power bi gives you
so let me now go ahead and create a
simple table where we will see the
quantity and the profit made in each
city so under visualizations i'll select
tables
let me resize this
so under values
first i'll add the city column
followed by
the quantity column
and
the profit column
let's do some formatting
so under column headers
let me change the font color to white
and let's add a background
let me increase the
text size also
let's make it 15.
similarly if you scroll down under
values
let's increase the text size
to 15 as well
and let's choose the font family
let's take consoles
so here
you can see all the cities
the quantity
sold in each city and the profit that
was made in each of these cities
now let me add a border to this
so now you can filter each of the cities
by region or by state for example if i
choose central
as my region
it will give you all the cities that lie
in the central region
similarly
you can also search for any state for
example
i am taking minnesota
so under minnesota
you can see all the cities
and the quantity as well as the profit
made
let me now uncheck the filters
now let me go ahead and filter this
table
in terms of profit so i'll sort by
profit
you can see
have our cities
sorted in terms of profit
so new york city made the highest amount
of profit followed by los angeles and
seattle below you can see the total
units that were sold and the total
profit that was made from all the cities
so you can also filter down the quantity
sold and the profit made by each year as
well as by region and state
so let's see
suppose i am choosing
east as the region
so under east it tells you the states
that are present
let's
go for delaware
and let's select 2016 as my year
so you can see
the cities
that lie under delaware state
and the quantity as well as the profit
they made in 2016. similarly let's
select
massachusetts as the state and let's
go for another year for example 2017.
you can see
all the cities that are present under
massachusetts the quantity sold and the
profit that was made below you can see
the total quantity and the profit
let me uncheck all these
now moving ahead
let's analyze the sales by each state
and the category of product for this
we'll create a clustered bar chart so
under visualizations i'll select
clustered bar chart let me resize a bit
under access
i'll take the state column
i'll take category on to legend
and under values
i'll put the sales column
so you can see here
we have the sales for each category
under each state
for example california state made the
highest amount of sales under technology
category and it made the lowest amount
of sales under office supplies
if i scroll down you can see all the
states
and the sales they made
for each category
i'll go back to the report
now let's use some filters
you can filter here for example if i
want to check
the sales by each state and category for
2015 i can just
click on 2015
and it will tell you the sales that were
made
now
let's do some formatting to this bar
chart
we'll change the colors for each of the
categories
similarly we change the color for office
supplies
and finally for the technology
so now we have our bar chart ready
moving on now let me add a border to
this bar chart
okay
so now that we have seen our sales by
state and category let's now check the
profit by year and category for that
we'll create an area chart
i'll resize this chart
now
under axis
i'll take the year column
under legend
i'll take the category column
and
under values
i'll take profit
so we have an area chart that depicts
the profit by each year and the category
to which the product belong to
i'll go to the format tab
and under data colors
i'll choose some colors
let's change furniture to this blue
color
i'll take office supplies
red color
and technology i'll use a green color
now you can use the filters
for example you can check the profit
that was made by each year and category
under east region
so you can see here
in 2017 technology made the highest
amount of profit while furniture
at the lowest
similarly
let's
check for south region
you can see in south region in 2016
technology made the highest amount of
profit
and
furniture made the lowest in 2017
office supplies made the highest amount
of profit and furniture was the lowest
i'll uncheck this south region filter
similarly you can also see the sales by
each state so under state slicer you can
choose whichever state you want and
check the profit it made by that year or
category
for example i'll choose connect to cut
so you can see the profit connect cut
state made in each of these years
i'll uncheck it
let us move ahead and now let's see
profit that was made and the quantity
that was sold by each category and
subcategory of the product so for this
i'll choose the line and cluster column
chart
so
i'll select from the visualizations now
under shared access
i'll select the category column under
column series i'll take the sub category
column
under column values
i'll choose profit
and
i'll choose quantity
under the tooltips
now you can see
the profit that was made under each
category and the sub category
for technology category
copiers sub category made the highest
amount of profit the quantity sold was
234.
similarly
if you check for furniture category
we didn't make any profit for table
subcategory
and as well as for bookcases
under office supplies paper subcategory
made the highest amount of profit
now let me go ahead
and add a border to this
fine
moving ahead now we will see the seals
by each segment for that
let's create a funnel so from
visualizations i'll take the
funnel
and
i'll drag
segment onto group
and the sales column onto values
so you can see here
the sales that were made by each segment
this picture clearly depicts
that consumer segment made the highest
amount of sales
next was corporate and then home office
now
let's do some color formatting so the
default color is this blue
i'll click on so all
now will give individual colors to each
of the segments
using custom color
let's give a hexadecimal value
similarly we'll change the color for the
corporate segment
and finally for the home office segment
now let me go ahead and give a border to
it
so if you want to analyze the sales
by segment and for
a particular region or state or any
particular year you can do that so let's
select
for east region
and
let's take
new jersey as the state
for year 2014 suppose
so you can see here
corporate segment made the highest
amount of sales followed by consumer and
home office
let me uncheck
these filters
so our second report is ready where we
analyzed the sales quantity profit at
region level state level and by year so
i can rename this
as
region and
state
next we will analyze the sales quantity
profit
in terms of categories and sub-category
of products so let me first copy this
text box
and
create a new tab
i'll paste that text box here and
change the title to
say
category
and sub category level analysis
first
we'll create a
slicer
where we'll take
the category as filter
so
if i want i can directly copy it
from my previous tab
and change the fields so let me copy
this and paste it here
i'll sync it
and let me remove the region field and
add
category onto the field
so you can see
we have the three categories here
let me copy paste this again
and
let me take the sub category now
so i'll select this
and
i'll drag subcategory onto the field so
here you can see we have all the sub
categories
and above we have the categories
let me resize this a bit
with that now let's analyze the sales
and profit by region and segment
to do this we'll use a tree map
so let's see how you can build a tree
map under visualizations i have tree map
let me select it
i'll move it to the top
and expand it a bit
now
under group
i'll select
region column
under details i'll take
segment
i'll take the sales column under values
and
let's take profit
on two tooltips
so if i expand this
you can see the sales and profit by each
region and segment for example in the
west region you have
consumer corporate and home office
as the segments and you can see
consumer segment made the highest amount
of sales and profit
while home office made the lowest amount
similarly you can check for the other
regions as well
now
let's give a border to this tree map and
under data colors let me change the
color of the
regions
scroll down
custom color
let me choose my own color
let's take this as a gray color
and finally
for the west region
so now you can select individual
categories and sub categories to check
the sales and profit by region and
segment for example
if i select
furniture as my category
you can see the changes that were made
to the tree map
you can also select office supplies and
see
how the sales and profit changes
similarly you can also go ahead
and select whatever sub categories you
want
and then check the sales and profit by
region and segment with that let me now
create a pie chart
to see the quantity and the sales by
each segment
so i'll go and select a pie chart
let me resize this
if you want you can increase the size of
this tree map also
so let me go ahead
and select segment onto the legend
under values i'll take quantity
and
sales under tooltips
so this pie chart
depicts the quantity and the sales that
were made by each segment as you can see
consumer segment made the highest amount
of sales and had the highest quantity
sold
while home office had the least number
of quantity sold and the least number of
sales
let's add a border and
change the data colors
similarly i change the color for the
corporate segment let's make this
gray
and home office
i'll take the following color
move this a little to the right
now
let's build a scatter plot to analyze
the sales quantity and profit by each
subcategory
so under visualizations
i'll select scatter plot i'll resize
this
so i'll add
subcategory
onto legend
then i'll add sales onto the
x axis
quantity sold onto the y-axis
and under size
we'll take the profit column
if i expand this
you can see the sales quantity and the
profit that was made for each sub
category of products you can see here
subcategory phone has given us a
significant amount of sales with less
number of quantities sold and it has
given us a good amount of profit also
similarly sub category chairs has also
given us good amount of sales with close
to
2356 quantities sold and a good amount
of profit if you see this one which is
sub category paper it gave us less
amount of sales with more quantities
sold while it gave us good amount of
profit though so you may promote phones
or for example chairs to sell more since
it gives you more amount of profit with
less quantity sold
let's add a border to this
you can use the category filter suppose
if i choose for furniture
and expand this
you can see
under furniture subcategory furnacings
gave us the lowest amount of sales with
the highest number of quantities sold
but it gave us a decent amount of profit
sub-category tables gave us a decent
amount of sales with lesser number of
quantities sold but didn't give us any
profit
subcategory chairs gave us the highest
amount of sales and also the profit
i'll uncheck this
let's now create a line chart where we
can see the profit by each year and
quarter
so under visualizations
i'll select line chart
we resize this
so under access i'll take here
under legend
i'll take the quarter column
and under values
i'll take the profit column
so now you can see
the profit that was made
each year
and
the lines depict each quarter
so if you check for 2014
quarter four meet the highest amount of
profit while quarter two made the lowest
amount of profit while quarter one made
the lowest amount of profit similarly if
you see for 2016 you can see
quarter four made the highest amount of
profit
while quarter one made the lowest
if you check for 2017
you see quarter three and quarter four
almost made the same amount of profit
while
quarter two made the lowest amount of
profit i go back
now you can filter these by categories
also suppose if i see for technology
you can check the amount of profit that
was made in each year and in each
quarter for technology category
let's add a border to this
likewise we'll now create another line
chart that will depict the sales by each
year and quarter
so
let me copy paste this
i'll drag this to the right
now i'll remove
profit from values and add sales
let me uncheck this also
so here you can see we have the sales by
each year and quarter
now if you see for 2014 again quarter
four made the highest amount of sales
and quarter one in 2014 made the lowest
you see for 2016 you can see 2016 also
quanta 4 made the highest amount of
sales and quarter one made the lowest
we'll go back
so our final report is ready where we
analyzed the sales quantity sold the
profit at category and subcategory level
i can go ahead and rename this as
category
and
subcategory
let me save this now if you want
you can also filter it by sub categories
for example if i select
chairs as my subcategory
so for chairs you can see the sales that
was made by each year and quarter
so in 2017 quarter four made the highest
amount of sales while quarter one made
the lowest amount of sales for chairs
similarly
you can select other sub categories also
for example
let me take
some other category like
machines
let's see the profit now
so for machine sub category
you can see in 2014 quarter four made
the highest amount of profit while
quarter three
made the lowest amount of profit
now if you check for 2015 you can see
quarter three made the highest amount of
profit in chairs while quarter one made
the lowest amount of profit
let's uncheck this
so now we are almost done building our
report using the superstore sample data
set
so we have our three reports ready you
can see the first one was overall sales
the second report we created
by taking region state and the year as
filters so we had a region and state
level analysis and finally we analyzed
the sales quantity and the profit sold
by category and subcategory so i have
arranged all these graphs and charts so
that it looks little better now
let me go to this publish option on the
top so that we can publish this report
onto the power bi dashboard
so i'll click on publish
i'll save it
you can select the destination here i
have only one destination which is my
workspace so i'll choose it
and select
so there you go
publishing to power bi it was successful
i'll close it
and
let me move to
my power bi service
i'll refresh it for once
so under my workspace
you can see
we have
the dashboard report
so below you can see there are three
tabs that we created the first one is
overall sales
the second one is sales by region the
third one is by category and subcategory
now
to put this reports onto the dashboard i
need to pin each one of these
visualizations
so
let me pin one by one
so it asks where would you want to pin
it to i'll select the existing dashboard
or better let's create a new dashboard
let's say
power bi
dashboard
spin it
i'll close this
similarly let's spin the remaining ones
i'll select power bi dashboard again pin
it
let's spin everything
so this slicer you can't pin it
let's do the remaining ones
same will do for
the donut chart
as well as
for the pie chart
now
now if i go to
my dashboards
and select power bi dashboard
you can see
we have a one page
dashboard
here
you can resize
all the charts and graphs
let me resize it
and move it to the top
so we have our first canvas here
which tells you the overall sales the
profit and the units that were sold over
different states different segments
and by categories
so one of the important feature that
power bi service gives you is that you
can ask questions about your data and it
will tell you what the exact solution is
for example you can see here you have a
field where you can ask questions so for
example if i type
total sales
and hit enter
so it tells you the total amount of
sales that were made which is 2.3
million dollars similarly if i want to
find out the total
profit i can search for it here
hit enter
it will give you the exact amount of
profit that was made
let's do something else for example if
you want
total
profit
by
say year
and hit enter it gives you a nice line
chart where you can see the total profit
that was made over all the four years
next
suppose i search for total
quantity
sold
by
segment
see it gives me a bar chart where you
can see the total quantity that was sold
and
it gives you a list of options where you
can find out the total quantity that was
sold by city state order id first name
last name and many others so consumer
segment had the highest quantity sold
let's see for something else for example
if you want
the total
sales
by
say sub category
i'll choose the first one
see you have all the sub categories and
the total sales that they made so it's a
very interesting feature that power bi
gives you
go back
now if you want
you can go to the report menu
and if you want you can pin the other
visualizations as well
so another important feature about power
bi dashboard is that you can derive
insights from the visualization for
example
if i click on these dots and there's an
option you find view insights
i'll select it
so on the right you can see power bi has
itself given us some insights from the
data and the visualizations we have made
you can see sales by year and quarter
the sales by day of week and quarter
sales by shipment mode where you can see
the standard classic mode made the
highest amount of sales
you can also see the sales and count of
city by year
and many more now that brings us to the
end of this live session on power bi
full course i hope you liked it if you
have any questions then please feel free
to put them in the comments section
below
also don't forget to subscribe to the
simply known channel stay tuned for more
from simply loan
you